All right, according to the
script.
Now if he's going to start with you, so you can't be quiet.
Uh, speak.
Speak.
I live.
Yeah.
Uh, session session current.
Okay.
Um, all right.
So I'm going to do.
Uh, Bob, any questions from the map itself?
You good?
Uh, just trying to spell out the names.
Okay, cool.
All right.
Uh, because you will, you will have to be the one to guide them.
Just so you know.
Yeah, by the way, that's what I'm going to do.
You know, yeah, by the way, there are any markings like where the dungeon was.
I'm guessing that this is the gate.
Yeah, back to the gate.
And you guys have to figure it out where the fuck, how the fuck or whatever.
Uh, okay.
Last time after you're in counter with graph, uh, you split ways.
You got your ship back and you made your way toward one of the two log poses you had.
Uh, one of the log poses pointed another way, one of them pointed another way.
You chose the one that you stole from the merchant, uh, back on the WG.
Zoo.
Okay, whatever.
All right.
So as, uh, you moved forward, uh, you encountered an island and you decided to stop by because
it had a, uh, fair amount of forest.
So you thought, okay, maybe Tink or I can grab some of the animals he needs for the zoo
and take it back on the ship.
Uh, as you got off the island, there was something very eerie about the whole situation.
The people were very quiet.
They moved away as soon as they saw Roma speaking loudly and then you noticed the signs that
said, uh, sound is the same.
As you made your way toward the capital, um, you encountered a strange woman in between
while Roma threw one of the guards right into the ocean, which was grabbed by a translucent
tentacle and pulled down in the lake.
Um, the strange woman, uh, revealed herself to Baptiste, Baptiste seemed to know maybe
who she was.
And, uh, in the blink of an eye she disappeared right from right in front of you.
Uh, Baptiste took charge of one of the horse that the guards were riding on as one of the
other horse riders blew a whistle and then ran away.
Um, as Baptiste got to the gate, he pretended to be one of the, uh, from one of the houses,
house in, uh, one of the nobility classes of this island that the woman told you about.
Uh, Bob seems to have spotted one of them through the eyes of Merlin heading into, uh,
which you may call like an abandoned, abandoned building.
And he was being very, um, quite about it, I guess.
That would be the word, I guess.
Um, so as Baptiste tried to get in, the way the guards talked to him broke something,
I guess, and he ran back and I guess we can take over from here, I think.
Right.
What happens then?
And yeah, is that abandoned building inside like the town?
Like we have to do the game.
Yeah, yeah.
It was inside the town.
You're at the start of the gates.
Uh, we're still, my fat ass is still trying to make it to the gate.
I think, I think last time you guys were hiding in the bushes while Baptiste was trying
to talk about.
Yeah, I'm the only one that actually went up at the horse.
Yeah.
Yeah, I guess so.
Fat asses are back there just, well, I wouldn't say Bob's there.
You're heavy ass.
You don't know.
Yeah.
Well, I'm a bit of class is walking up there.
Okay.
All right, let's get started.
So as the dead, thus from the shattered gate hangs in the air, the three guards aren't
just defeated.
They're foaming at the mouth.
Eyes rolled back, collapse in a heap.
You didn't touch them.
You sit on your horse, chest heaving for a second, the air around you felt heavy, like
physical pressure.
The word turned gray and your whale crushed theirs.
Now the feeling fades leaves you and with a spitting headache.
The rest of the party is trying to catch up.
All right, Baptiste, what are we thinking?
Do I see anybody else nearby?
There is no one nearby right now, but you do see Roma, Bob and Tigor trying to catch
up to Malfa.
Malfa is right now in one of the bushes near the gates.
But you do see a couple of mega phones with lights on top and they start to flash red.
And soon enough, you hear these words from a loud, like, ethereal voice that goes alert.
Desciples spike detected at Northgate.
Magnitude, legal.
Deploying house tremor.
And this message keeps repeating on the mega phones.
I was digng on Malfa's tongue and trying to get him to move the body out of eyesight
and also just to quickly get out the area.
Okay, so are you going to wait for Bob and Roma and Tigor to catch up?
No, I'm taking infected with the body out of sight first.
You should be able to move the bodies into like the bushes, but the gate itself is collapsed.
There is no saving that part.
You can move the bodies.
I don't think it would matter any much.
Again, again, he did not kill the guards.
They're knocked out.
They did.
Malfa's fist could not even touch one of the guards.
He just fell down and his fist touched the gate itself.
One of the guards was sent flying, but his fist just touched that one guard.
The other two were just knocked out from the wave of hockey.
Do you hear Malfa?
Bob.
No, no, Baptiste.
Baptiste.
He's being raised to the gate.
It's just you two names that are too similar, man.
I don't know.
Baptiste, you don't really grasp what you did.
You do remember the feeling of hockey you felt this before, but you've never used it before.
At this point, I think Bob and everyone would be able to catch up.
Bob, you can hear the sirens going off.
You're the only guard that stopped doing that.
My body is not built for this kind of stuff.
Bob, where do we need to go?
And where's the cave?
Hold on.
We need to make it.
Fuck.
You don't have to.
Good.
It got me.
I found it.
Get you to go for the horse.
And it right here.
Oh.
Do you want the cave?
You want it there?
It's on the horse.
I forgot.
Was the cave in the slums?
Or where was it?
Yeah, yeah, toward the slums.
Guys, you got to go through the gate and to the right there.
I saw a lot of slums over there.
We got to hide there.
And I think that was where the noble went.
Hey, Bob, just leave the way.
Consider it.
[LAUGHTER]
So long as it was.
All right.
I need to drive.
As you get inside--
I want to ask you to be the one who needs to be on a horse.
OK, look at it.
As you get--
The horse would die.
[LAUGHTER]
The horse, at this point, can get inside.
But as soon as you get to the part of the alleys,
that Bob is walking in front of you is going through,
you definitely see the horse cannot fit through that place.
So you have to let it go.
Guys, I lost my day with high key.
You need to move it.
Do the guards have anything on them?
The guards only did have like spears.
And not like very long range--
they didn't really have anything long range.
They're just through spears whenever any threat came.
So I'm just taking their weapons away
and playing with trees somewhere or something.
OK, yeah, you can do that.
So what are we doing with the horse?
Are we still trying to take it?
Do you want to tie it up somewhere?
Or--
Oh, it's a bit of a nearby.
OK.
So you tie up the horse, and you're
moving through these quiet alleys.
You do see a bunch of people walking around.
But this time, instead of like cloths around their mouths,
the same, they have fully covered jaws with steel.
Their mouth has been basically shut close using steel.
And they're just trying to avoid you.
As you're walking through the alleyway,
they just stick to the sides of the alleys
and just try not to make eye contact as you walk past.
This definitely saw or heard the alarms,
and they just don't want anything to do with it at this point.
Can you guys as you are walking through--
let me move you to the alleys, actually?
OK.
You guys are able to see?
Yeah.
We have a man.
Hey.
It's hard to make maps, OK?
You don't give him shit.
OK.
Why the fuck are you able to see this thing?
Man, oh god.
I fucking hate myself.
[INAUDIBLE]
Are we going to have T-Gur--
take the horses back?
Burn their--
It's removed every cold shit I did, bro.
The maps are completely broken.
OK.
I don't know what happened.
Maybe the sink went wrong or something.
Goddamn it.
It's fine.
I worked so hard on this.
Goddamn it.
I shouldn't have fucking switched, bro.
I swear to god.
OK.
All right.
As you walk by the small alleyway into the building,
this is the building that Bob, you know,
the guy went inside.
So as you're walking through, can everyone
give me this 15 perception?
And you say, step to it.
And you said a DC 15?
Yeah, that's a lot of people.
Whoa, holy shit.
I have to see this part.
I see everything.
You see everything.
You see through the walls.
Goddamn it, Bob.
Bob, roll the zero.
Bob, I see nothing.
Oh my god.
Too busy, guys.
OK.
I'm too busy looking at the map.
Bob, roll the zero.
Holy shit.
Why did you roll the zero?
Yeah.
OK.
You were this-- OK.
I don't think no one-- no one knows this.
As you're walking through, no one knows this.
I'm not running.
Yeah.
I'm telling you.
No one else notices.
As you're walking through, Malfas,
you can hear sounds on top of these--
like what do you call it?
Fucking--
Hearts.
Whatever.
Yeah, hey, hey, hearts, whatever.
As you're walking through, you hear sounds--
very, very faint sounds.
No one can probably notice, but you are able to detect those.
And yeah, someone definitely is telling you guys.
Hailing Earth?
Yeah.
I mean, you don't know any Malfas, no?
While we're walking, I'm just going to say
there are people out there.
Who's that actually?
On the roof.
He's--
Play him on.
Come on.
Do it.
Yeah.
I can't just get on the roof.
OK, as you get up, you see a guy and another guy around here.
And one of them just sees you as you just basically jump.
And he just sees you and he's just taken a back as immediately
as you show your face to him.
And he's like, what the fuck?
And he gets back to this roof.
Malfas, as you stabilize yourself on this roof,
you see two more of the same people
like wearing same kind of clothes on top of them.
You can see that they're wearing this gray suits.
And in their hands, they have these tuning forks
in sort of like actual weapons.
As these two go, you're the one that broke the gate.
And the other one kind of echoes his saying.
And he also goes like broke the gate.
And more of them show up from behind Baptist and Roma.
You at this point can also see him.
Bob, you were just walking straight.
You were just not looking at any of it.
[INAUDIBLE]
Bob, you put your right.
Yeah.
And at this point, they just take out their tuning forks
and they go, you've committed a sin.
And it will not go punish, unpunished.
And it can get ready for encounter.
You haven't had a fight in so long.
Yeah.
Well, you didn't do anything last session essentially.
Aren't you proud of us?
No, we'll see.
I'm going to see you.
I think I'm going first.
Oh my god, holy shit.
Melph is on the roll.
Bob, roll for initiative, please.
Bob is just lost.
He has no way.
[INAUDIBLE]
First round.
God, damn, remember the whole thing.
He--
Well, we have a tiger.
Bob.
Yeah, a seagull.
Yeah.
Bob.
[INAUDIBLE]
If we're like, essentially--
All right.
He's not in his tiger suit, by the way.
It's just his old token that I'm using.
He's in his human form.
With form?
I don't know if it's called the form.
He's just real.
[INAUDIBLE]
Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah, maybe he'll come around.
All right, Melph, it's up to you.
You essentially just jump up on the grass hut.
And what do you want to do?
[INAUDIBLE]
Oh, so they seem so keen on being an S.
Let's hit him.
All right.
Where is it?
The beat.
Oh.
Bob.
Yeah.
[COUGH]
That will hit.
That will.
As your fists connect to this guy,
you do feel like they have essentially no armor.
These people were trained to be like very quiet, just
stealthy, and they're supposed to be assassins.
They're not really like fighter types.
They're supposed to just come in, kill you, and go away.
But yeah, as soon as you touch them,
his arm essentially just buckles under the weight
of your fist.
And yeah, that will just break off one of its bones.
Just crack it open.
And he just lies down, just screaming.
As that happens, let me see.
Which one is this guy?
This guy right in front of you, Baptiste.
He sees that happen.
He jumps to the other side, and he's
going to take out a blogon.
And he's going to shoot with the blogon toward Malthus.
Oh, I still have a bonus action.
Thank you.
Oh, sorry, sorry.
Yeah, go ahead.
Is he down or is this lady there?
No, no, he's standing.
He's just grabbing his arm.
OK.
But that was also hit.
Malthus is on a roll.
Oh, shit.
Yeah.
As a minimum damage.
As one of your fists connects, he moves back up it.
You soon just dash forward and just slam him in his face.
Yeah, he seems like he's--
you can see blood pouring out of his nose at this point
within the mask itself.
All right, now this guy is going to shoot a blogon towards you.
He's going to be a movement.
Yeah, yeah.
OK.
It's not just a style.
He's going to fly up tomorrow.
OK, as you get away, I don't think it's going to matter.
He has like 100 feet on the thing.
That was like 15.
Let me move another 15.
There you go.
He essentially jumps up, runs towards you.
And as you're running away, he's going to attack you again.
It's not going to be a--
It's going to be another one.
Oh, goddammit.
I keep--
OK.
That's minimum damage.
No, fucking change the thing again.
[SIGHS]
I think it's 1D6, right?
Goddammit.
I fucking hate whatever foundry.
I don't know how it happened.
Let me roll it again.
Whenever I think I got what this shit is about,
oh, you're all the same thing.
Nice.
It surprises me.
OK.
He shoots this thing that hits you right in the neck.
And you start to feel woozy as soon as it just gets to you.
Deflect missiles.
OK, deflect missiles.
Go ahead.
How many do you think you should all like four times?
It only hit once.
One of them.
So five.
For five.
I do at least six damage to deflect missiles.
So-- OK, the me--
I wouldn't hit.
--and do damage.
OK, there you go.
So as the--
as it's more like blow needle, like comes to your face,
you just swatted away as you keep running away.
All right, next is going to be this guy that you damaged.
He's going to dash-- no, not dash.
Just run towards you.
He's going to take the tuning fork.
And you see him press kind of a button.
And the tuning fork is now in between--
you see some electricity sparks going off in between them.
And he's going to hit twice with that.
He's going to try it.
You're going to try to hit twice with that.
You're going to use a light meter electricity?
Well, no, not in his form.
Yeah.
Let me go normal.
Going to be--
Yeah, that hits.
Normal.
OK, let me roll another one.
That doesn't hit.
OK, so as he just smacks you with one of its tuning
forks, that will hit you for four damage.
And he points to the other ones.
And he goes, let's take this one down first.
So the rest are also going to probably target you.
Yeah, he's the boss.
Robots, your turn.
OK, that's a low blow.
Micer? Yeah, it's a change.
So how tall is this room?
It should be about 10 feet.
It's not that tall.
You should be able to jump it.
Well, that's a bonus action if you want to jump.
The question for you.
Mm-hmm.
Would my electroability be able to produce play?
Like if I try to put it on the floor.
I mean, yeah, yeah, yeah.
OK, so--
So do you just want to burn down slums?
That's what you're trying to do.
I'm just trying to understand what your plan is.
Look, he's going to be on a cuff head.
I still don't want to climb on the roof.
I'm just trying to light the roof on fire.
Have these two fucks die.
Mm-hmm.
Like fall.
[SIGHS]
I just want to--
Go ahead, you can try.
I'm not stopping you from doing anything.
I'm just going to say it's going to have repercussions.
That's it.
This whole area is going to catch on fire.
Yeah, it's not this.
It's going to grab this, and then it's going to grab this,
and then it's going to grab the next house, and so on.
And that's what I'm asking.
Is there like a shit ton of houses over here?
Yeah, yeah.
They're just changed together.
Yeah, damn it.
So I've got a--
All right, let me get my fat ass up there.
All right.
Team plus jumping up.
That's the everything, right?
Yes, yes.
I mean, I'd allow you to move to this guy if you want to.
Oh, no.
I want him to step into me.
OK.
Because I can't swing if my action was to jump up there.
Your bonus was to jump up.
Oh, the bonus was-- oh, stay left.
Yeah, I'm going in the swing and fucking.
Hey, I'm doing this.
You doing this, eh?
All right, where's my pan?
Who has my fat?
Are you fucking kidding me?
Oh, rumble.
I know I fucked up.
All right, as you swing, this guy just ducks around
and tries to get around you.
All right, Baptiste.
Remember, you ain't got wing.
Oh, shit.
Rome will be the thing that didn't care to be like, hey, you ain't got wing.
And you can't land a hit.
You're right, of barbarian and evil.
I like--
All right, that's going to hit.
So restart.
Oh, fuck him up, bro.
Oh, my god.
Jesus Christ.
You take it off his head.
No, unfortunately, that's not going to kill him.
But yeah, you essentially just as he's trying to sneak around
to Rome and try to get to Malfus, Baptiste, you just jump up
and just pound his head in.
Yeah, and basically just bounces off the roof of this thing
and just tries to get up.
It's Tegor's turn.
Tegor's in a--
Of course, yeah.
Yeah.
This is the first time Tegor sees us in action.
And we--
Like, I threw a dude in the lake.
Yeah.
[INAUDIBLE]
Or my bad, Baptiste just disintegrated a fucking gate.
Like, you know, we jump--
now we jump in spies, like Tegor got in there.
What the fuck these guys are?
Yeah.
Tegor is at this point he's panicking a bit.
He doesn't know what's happening, but he takes out
like these claws and he just puts on these gauntlets.
And he's going to look at Bob.
He goes, well, what do we do here, Bob?
Do we just fight the guy?
OK, we chill out.
These guys are going to do all this stuff.
Chill out.
OK, so that's how it works.
OK, come on, go.
So Tegor's just going to move up.
And he's not going to do anything.
Yeah.
Get ready to dodge if they try to attack.
OK, he's just looking at this guy and trying
to see what if he'll attack you guys,
then he will maybe fight back.
All right, Bob, be certain.
And you're telling me this all of these areas made of hay,
that means inflammable material, right?
Yes, yes.
Great.
Bob, it is real.
I realized.
I'm going to set the house on fire.
Literally everything I do, as far as fire, I have fire
bolts.
I have burning hands.
I have flaming fear.
Which one do you want?
I'm on a megafob.
I'm just turning a glass.
Yeah, I'm just going to pass.
Come on.
You're already a dodge.
Right, you told me to do this.
You're not going to do shit.
Yeah, I'm trying to cast, told the dead,
but there is no cast spell over here.
What?
Told the dead.
Don't cast it, will.
No, it just says save d20.
Just click on save d20.
Where is the cast?
Where is the cast spell?
Just click on save d12, and that should be.
Sorry.
Well, you want to cast 12 of the dead?
Yeah.
But there is no--
It's not just--
It's not just about you.
But it's your fault.
OK.
No, look at told of the dead.
When you click it, does it not save d12 damage?
Yeah, it says that--
Just click on.
Click on it.
Yeah.
OK.
Everything is changed now.
Yeah, yeah.
It's a bit different from last time.
OK.
Yeah, this guy.
Which one?
This guy?
Up here?
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
OK.
Bob, your hand splits open.
And bullet essentially leaves it.
And this guy gets struck by it right in the head.
Let me see what happens.
Does it?
Yeah.
Yeah, it just gets right in the head.
Unfortunately, the force of the bullet
is not strong enough at this distance.
So it only does like--
Bob?
Yeah.
D12.
Roll the D12.
No, it's supposed to be D8.
I don't know what--
OK.
Yeah.
Not that it was 12.
So it's going to deal four damage.
Let me do a plus damage.
Next is this guy on the roof that you just hit.
He's going to look at you.
He goes--
Right.
He looks in his pockets.
He grabs another whistle, the same kind of whistle
that you saw earlier.
But this one has longer noses on its top.
And he blows it.
This time, the whistle does make a sound.
Last time, it didn't end.
Did not.
But this time, it does make a sound.
And it sounds like a subwoofer going off.
Boom, boom, boom, boom.
Like this.
And yeah, that's going to be his move.
But he's also going to bonus action dash.
And let me go.
And jump through the gap.
Oh, sorry.
Jump through this.
He told you it was a chill out squad.
I look at the goal.
OK, I'm going to change it.
He's going to jump through here and surround you, but at least.
The next is this guy.
And he's going to try to bonus dash--
sorry, cutting action dash.
He's going to surround the mouthfuls.
And he's just going to start wailing.
And it's going to hit.
There you go.
Another one.
OK, as he takes two of the tuning forks,
and he just tries to attack you right around the back.
Boom, boom, twice.
And it's going to be it.
He just ends off saying, just hold them off
until the tremors show up.
They'll take care of this.
All right, Mel, let's see your turn.
Yep.
[SIGHS]
[INAUDIBLE]
Well, that's an atroini.
Jesus fucking cries, bro.
You weren't--
[INAUDIBLE]
That's another D6.
You have another one.
[SIGHS]
Did you not roll a crit?
Yeah, but I actually--
Oh, that's not that-- that's not a shake.
OK, 12.
All right, yeah, that's going to kill him.
Like, literally on the dot.
Do you want to kill him?
Or do you want to just knock him unconscious?
We just need one alive to be fair.
All right, tell me how do you want to kill him?
Huh.
I'm just grabbing that stupid fork and sticking it in his eyes.
OK, you just grab his tuning fork and just fucking stab him
right in the head as he just falls down, blurt splurts off
as the other guy sees this.
And he looks kind of terrified.
OK, this guy is--
[INAUDIBLE]
--this guy's dead, all right?
Next is--
It's still me.
Yeah, go ahead.
Come on, man, it's so before I do everything else.
I'm just going to look at him and say, still want to go.
OK, that's it.
Well, there's the answer.
Oh, do you want to go?
Did you say that?
Yeah, do you still want to continue this or do you hope just--
He, for a moment, thinks about it.
But then he looks at it as tuning fork
and he just stands his ground.
All right.
Uh, I like your gut kid.
I can just see the whole time Baph C's character
sitting there jumping like he's Muhammad Ali.
Like, throw a jab.
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah, that's going to hit.
Oh, my fucking down, Baph C.
What the fuck?
Minimum damage.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Maybe ask her what to not say.
[LAUGHTER]
Oh, sorry.
Did I not do it?
Do you realize it's every time like you roll a crit,
do decent amount of damage?
Then the next roll he'll hit with, but then do shit damage.
Yeah.
Malthus has rolled 20s already today.
I think that hasn't even been an hour.
That's all I have to do.
I know.
This is the end.
All right.
Next after, Malthus just lands another hit right to the other guy's chest.
I'm assuming you're just dashing away, right?
You dash away and surround the guy.
Surround the guy who is now surrounding Baph Tees.
The guy right in front of you are Roma.
Will take his cunning action, and this time he will just--
cunning action disengage.
So you're not able to.
I think hit him.
Doesn't send him to do that?
No.
No, no.
He disengaged yet.
He goes down, and he's going to go stealth now.
Let me see.
Oh god, OK.
He lands on a crate and just makes a fucking big sound.
So he's not stealthed anymore.
He was trying to hide, but that's going to be not working.
So that's his move.
Let me move the other guy.
This guy is dead.
Roma's your turn.
All right.
Wait.
Future Mojo.
Thanks for you, even if you think this engage action.
Sentinel?
He does take an attack.
That's right.
OK.
Go ahead.
You have it.
Have it at advantage.
You do have an advantage.
Don't miss the game.
OK.
You're not able to hit him.
As he just sneaks by another one of your hits,
yeah, you're just swinging a miss.
All right.
What are you doing?
That was your reaction.
So you can still do your action.
Yeah.
Yeah, I was just going to move here and soon on this dude.
All right.
Go ahead.
But you're not surrounding.
Does it work if you're not literally
the opposite of another person?
No.
I tell you, really.
Yeah, I'm going to say he has enough leeway to get away.
So I'm going to say just roll normally.
You know it, manage.
That's fine.
But I'm going to be pissed because I just miss twice.
Yeah.
All right.
You go into your rage.
Yeah, that's going to hit.
11.
Let me see.
OK.
Yeah.
Yeah, as you bonk him right.
Oh, wait.
Why did it go at damage?
I don't know what the fuck is wrong with this thing.
Keeps damaging the wrong people.
And do damage.
And then there you go.
Never mind.
Be quiet.
I was going to ask you about adding your rage damage.
It does.
It does, I think.
Are you in rage?
Yeah.
I should have been.
Yeah, I used it.
Yeah, it does not apply rage for some reason.
Like it shows that I use my uses that took one away.
Why didn't it apply the ability?
I don't know.
I'm sorry to go ahead.
Hold on.
Let me see effects.
There you go.
And then there you go.
OK, now it's doing that.
Maybe effects.
Still, there's no rage in your effects section for some reason.
Whatever, just add two to this.
So that's going to be 13.
Let me check.
Yeah, it's plus three, right?
You already have plus three in your strength.
So that's just a strength modifier.
OK, it's going to be 11th to 13.
Let me do that.
Everything I have to do is fucking manually.
What the fuck is the point of this thing?
OK, as you've bonked him right in the face,
he staggers a bit.
And that's going to be your turn.
Baptiste, what are you doing?
Thanks.
Swinging for the fence.
Yeah, it's not going to hit.
As you try to swing, even though he's just staggered,
he-- OK, yeah, that's going to hit.
He ducks down, but this punch is going to connect.
Roll the damage first.
Let's see if it actually kills him or not.
Yeah, that's going to finish him off.
What do you want to do?
Knock him out, kill him.
That-- we do need one alive, so I'll knock this one out.
OK, let's pick him off one by one.
I really want to-- what's going on?
Go block this other dude off.
Oh, we won't let me jump down.
Let me do that for you.
There you go.
Just want to box him in.
All right, this guy's knocked out.
OK, as you fly up--
not-- sorry, sorry.
Can't do that anymore.
As you just dash and jump down, you see this guy trying
to struggle and trying to take one of his feet out of one
of the crates lying there in the corner.
You surround him.
All right, it's he goes time and he looks at Bob
because are you sure we're not supposed to do anything here?
We just stand here and doing nothing.
Bob?
Tomorrow, Bob?
Are we supposed to just stand here, Bob?
I can't hear you, Bob.
If I was saying anything.
I don't know what happened.
Robert.
Robert?
Robert, what's going on here, guys?
Roberto, cyborg, Bob.
Is this not working?
No, now it's working.
Yes.
OK, I was trying to talk all this time.
Yeah.
They don't need our help.
Bob is going to send Merlin to the sky to see
because that guy obviously calls someone.
So Bob is trying to see where they are
or how far they are, whoever he called.
Your Merlin flies up around here.
From the eyes of Merlin, you do see a guy stepping out
of this building.
It's the same guy that you saw earlier.
Yeah, he steps out.
He's trying to figure out what the hell is happening.
But that only you know about him.
OK, Bob is going to run to him.
OK?
We're going to be safe here.
It's going to be 60, right?
Let me go.
Wait.
So do you want to go to the bathroom?
That's not how it works.
You have to go here and then you go here.
So I guess you would be around somewhere around--
no, no.
Your back is against him.
So you can't see him right now.
Yeah, Bob, come around here.
No, you come around here first.
You're here.
We're out and pointing.
Yeah, OK.
And Tigger's going to follow you around there as well.
So I'm assuming that's both of your actions.
Let's move on to this one guy that's still somehow--
oh, no, he's unconscious now, mate.
[LAUGHS]
If he did--
Wait, so is everyone unconscious?
I thought he was dead.
I thought that he's killed him.
I knocked him right now.
Oh, save left.
Yeah.
He's been killed over here.
This one guy is still alive.
He sees everyone dying in front of him.
And this time, he's just going to run away.
And with his dash, he should be able to get away.
Get back here, pussy.
Dozey-do.
Face him down, Roma.
My father doesn't get nervous.
I just got Roma to chase him down.
Yeah, yeah, I was fucking Roma to chase him down.
[LAUGHS]
All right, Malfus, he's gone.
He's gone.
Don't try to get to him.
He's off the map.
You know what?
Let me do a stealth.
If he succeeded, the stealth I would say he's gone.
[LAUGHS]
Do that.
No, he's not gone.
He also falls off and gets into one of these crates.
[INAUDIBLE]
Get it, Malfus.
Those crates are a place really bad for something.
How far can I chuck a spear?
Oi.
All right.
So that was a bonus access to dash.
[LAUGHS]
I'll get to answer you.
The week he says 20 to 60 feet.
What?
I'll fall in the water.
Fucking new troves, people.
It's 20.
What?
All right, I couldn't hear.
16.
16 hits?
Yes, 16 hits.
I was so sure.
[LAUGHS]
That is not enough to kill him.
As you hit him--
Oh my god.
Who are targeting?
Who have you targeted that it has been taking damage so far?
This one down here.
I see.
This one down down here.
This one down down.
All right.
As you try to hit him, he takes
one hit around his back, but he's
trying to still get away from you.
It's going to be-- this guy, this guy right in front of you,
Baptist, is now taking out his blow gun.
And he's going to hit you.
All right.
Do you want to do deflect missiles?
Of course.
Let me roll the damage and see if--
yeah, four.
Yeah, you should be, I think, able to--
what is your base deflection?
It's 9.
9.
9, yeah.
Yeah, you should be able to deflect it.
If you want to deflect it, you can deflect it
or you can just, you know, just swat it away.
I'm just swatting it away.
OK.
As you try to blow another of those needles
towards you, you just swat it away.
And you just start menacingly walking up to him,
same as Balfas, starting to fucking menacingly walking up
to this guy.
All right, let me see.
What the fuck, man?
I don't understand why they don't remove the combatants
once they're defeated.
Yeah.
They were used to do that before.
It's just not doing that anymore.
I almost hit her.
Shit.
You said I could throw a gun at you.
At this point, this guy runs up, gets up on this roof.
And--
Who the fuck is you?
What's music?
You see, this guy walks up.
At this point, I think Roma.
And Baptiste, you would notice him.
And you see, this guy has red scraggly hair.
And he also carries a guitar on his back, like electric guitar.
And he--
Let me see.
Are you suspecting him as a woman?
He has a leather vest and a red scarf around his neck.
As he gets up on top, he riffs the guitar.
And you feel your energies lifted up, Roma.
Let me do--
What do you mean, lifted up?
Like pumped up?
Yeah, you feel pumped up.
You got my biggest body on.
This is my bard.
I've watered with--
Oh, you.
You're out of control.
All right.
You have for the next 10 minutes.
What the fuck is this die?
I think D6, right?
Yeah, D6.
All right.
He does not see anything.
He just riffs his guitar.
And that's it.
All right, Roma, what are you doing?
Shit.
I'm moving here.
OK.
Let's go here.
Why isn't it moving?
35 feet.
What the fuck?
Why isn't it moving?
He's just dead.
There you go.
What's happening on me?
He's a canvas.
I'm even hitting space hard to have it moving.
Let me-- I think he's right in front of you.
That's why it's not moving.
OK.
Go ahead.
Move me five more feet.
Oh, let's try--
Yeah.
You want a dash?
No, I want to see if I can throw that job.
How far is that?
Let me see.
That it's 45--
60 feet.
I think you can.
Yeah, let's go for it.
I got one.
Yeah.
I'm part of getting free, Sid.
Come on now.
So what do you want to do on a string?
No, click on the javelin.
Don't you have the javelin?
Just click on the javelin.
Oh, fuck me.
Yeah.
You can add your D6 die if you want to roll the D6.
This roll won D6.
Yeah, that's going to be hitting him.
What do you want to do?
I've thrown that javelin, bro.
This is part of the type of shit, like--
Yeah.
All right.
You chuck the javelin.
Let's see if that actually kills him or not.
Uh, no, it does not kill him.
Will you go to have a javelin thickening?
Yeah.
As you roll this javelin, it hits him right in his back,
and he falls down.
Yeah, that's going to be it.
And as soon as you do that, he goes, good on you, man.
And he starts to riff again.
Baptiste, you're turned.
You're just just me and down here.
Yeah.
I appreciate your sirens.
Shit.
[LAUGHS]
Oh.
Light tab.
You said a light tab.
Is he still up?
What was it?
26?
Yeah, he's still up.
He's barely-- he's barely standing up.
At this point, you just grabbed its collar,
and just fucking hit him right in his face.
He's just not doing it.
He's just limp in your hands.
But yeah, he's still up.
One more time.
Yeah, this is going to hit.
God damn, you were fucking him up.
Yeah, this-- this will either kill him or knock him out.
What do you want to do?
Roll my stuff, sage.
I was knocking him out.
All right.
With the last hit, he just puts his hand in front of him.
And your fist just connects to both his hands.
His matches his head, and he falls down.
It's going to blow brutal, man.
The guy on top looks at you, as he says that.
I think we should move this party somewhere else then.
He gets off and starts walking away.
And he looks at you, essentially,
baptism.
He just signals you in.
All right, you guys are out of combat.
Malfus, you're still walking up to this guy.
I'm going to say, out of combat, he's just given up
at this point.
He's just trying to crawl away.
What are you doing?
Probably not come out.
Not what he's doing.
I'm so--
Make sure you grab my jav.
[LAUGHTER]
He's like, roll my thing, this is yours.
Yeah, I'll walk him out and grab him back to the other side
of the room.
Yeah.
All right.
I'm dragging him out.
I'm bias puller.
[LAUGHTER]
I will signal to everybody to pick up all the knockup
once and jive them together.
All right, they all bring them one by one.
Even T-Guard gets up and grabs one of them
and leaves them here.
[INAUDIBLE]
Really need one of them, right?
Yeah, one of them is--
[INAUDIBLE]
Both of them, the two that Baptiste knocked out
are still unconscious.
[INAUDIBLE]
Why can't I move my dude?
Now you can.
I think it's just boundaries here on the buildings.
That's why.
All right.
This guy just looks at you, Baptiste,
and he's going to lead you inside this house.
He shuts the door.
A rest of you can come in as he's just leading all of you inside.
Are you--
[INAUDIBLE]
No.
Are you guys taking any of the unconscious ones
or just leaving them there?
Yeah, we're taking them all.
Yeah, we're taking them there.
The two dead ones, except for those--
don't fucking actually grab them.
It's fine.
I'll say that they're with you.
OK, the guy at this point just lets you all in,
and he shuts the door.
And he sits down in one of these boxes.
So I suppose you're the ones who made all that rock
because of the door, of the gate, sorry.
And now this.
You put us in quite a pickle there.
First of all, you're the Duke of House.
Look, I'm no Duke.
I was abandoned by my family a long time ago.
I just wear these because it's the only thing
that they're allowed me to do.
And to be honest, the commoner clothing is not my style.
Anyway--
[INAUDIBLE]
OK, dude, dude.
Can you keep your volume a bit low?
We've already made the rockest out there.
The only reason I helped you is to get it done quick.
And I could just get you out of here.
First of all, what the hell do you want?
Why are you here?
Well, first we just stock up on supplies.
How fun of our--
chose one of the worst islands you possibly could.
So we found out once we got here.
Well, by now, you're--
your ship probably has been taken away by House Trimmer.
And they're going to come here looking for answers.
I don't want-- first of all, how the hell did you even
find this place?
Oh, no, this guy found it.
I pointed my owl and say that we know a bit about you
about being amicable to the commoners, then.
My partners here don't really like the situation
that's going on.
OK.
At this point, he is very, very of you.
So you look at his guitar, and he swings it around.
He points the end of the guitar towards you.
And you see two mausels coming out of it.
And he's ready to shoot.
As he goes, where did you hear this from?
The rebellion does not accept members.
Oh, so you are an rebellion.
OK.
At this point, it's an additional point, waiting.
[INAUDIBLE]
I think it's a reason to stop.
OK.
First of all, answer me.
Who told you that?
Well, I don't really know her.
Baptiste knows her.
Baptiste?
Well?
No, her specifically.
I just know of someone she's associated with.
Her name is Vera.
God damn it, that woman I shouldn't have trusted her.
So where is she now?
When we saw her, she was being drugged through the dirt.
We prayed her, and she decided that she wanted to leave.
OK.
That puts--
throws a wrench into our plans.
What do you mean?
Why did he--
says he's not going to like it, anyway, follow me.
He goes towards this white blue cloth lying around this wall,
and he just takes it up.
He clicks on a stone right alongside the wall,
and the rocky wall starts to slid down,
and you see a pathway leading downwards.
Hey, partner.
[GROANS]
What?
Oh, I'm just going to say this.
Great riff back there, by the way, like killer riff.
But what the fuck is your name?
You want us to follow you?
What's your name?
My name is Riff Sin.
Riff Sin hitting killer riff.
All right.
Baptiste.
Boss Riff.
Now, let's continue this conversation downstairs.
I don't want any of the tremors to find us.
OK, as he takes you inside of the base,
let me first fucking put your tokens in,
because God damn tokens got removed.
Hold on.
Before we go in, what are we going to do about the guards?
I really don't think you want them going to your secret hideaway,
or no one rear secret hideaway.
OK.
Can't do anything.
These echo spies, no, as well as anyone can,
that once the enemy is spotted, they might as well be dead.
I'll be taking care of them.
You don't kill them?
That's the only choice we have.
Shit.
I, Bob, do you show your worth?
Come on now.
Put them out.
Duff, huh?
What?
Put them out.
They've been re-c'mon now.
Can we go, we gotta kill them?
C'mon now.
Just stop screaming, man.
How many times do we have to tell you to follow me?
Jesus Christ.
As he leads you down, you enter this kind of like a bunker
where--
oh my god.
The walls here gone too.
Oh my god.
I'm gonna kill this one.
Walls.
You can see everything right?
God damn it.
It's like-- and there's no point in working anymore.
All right.
As you get inside, this old man also steps up to him.
You also see like a bunch of people just sitting on the floor.
All of them are basically wearing like the same rags.
And this old man also has like this metal mask on his face.
You also see a bunch of chalkboards lying around.
And on the chalkboards, you can see a lot of plans about a tower
that they're going to attack.
They're going to send these many people there,
these many people there, and all of the plannings
that they've been doing.
And as soon as the guy steps in with all of you,
the elder takes one of those chalkboards
and writes something on it.
And it basically says, what are you doing?
Why are you bringing strangers in?
Riff looks at the elder, he goes.
It's complicated.
I just had to take him away before they cause any more problems.
For now, just trust me, Kira, probably for a reason, told her.
Told these guys.
About us, so maybe they can help.
They probably need our help anyway, right?
He looks at you, Baptiste, and he nods.
And this is about him mentioning your ship, essentially.
We did come seeking your hope to solve things on this island.
So--
I'm saying.
Oh, welcome to the command center of the rebellion.
If you want it or not, this is it.
These are all the people we have.
Some of them can fight.
Most of them cannot.
And the only thing we can do is just live.
Each day, on day by day, just try to figure out
a solution to our problems.
Now, do you want to get rid of those spies?
If so, let me hand them over to the rest.
Looking around, how many people are in here?
This-- except for this place, you see all of this
is basically jam-packed.
There's even not even a lot of space.
But you see a lot of supplies here for a long period
in case they eventually pound her down or whatever.
I got a question.
Mm-hmm.
Go ahead.
Are you all--
you all want to do this, right?
You all want to join this resistance piece of the throne?
I just want to make sure you-- come on, Bob.
I need to know.
Because you might die here.
I need to know if you willing to help this person.
Take care.
Yeah.
Like, I'm at--
Keep-- keep going, bring new.
I want to make sure he-- he really did not for this.
If not, he got to get the fuck out.
I need to know.
I'm going to help you.
We don't even have our--
He Gore looks around and he just looks at, like,
kids and people just sitting with their faces
in that horrid mask.
And he just goes, oh, I feel horrible wearing my own masks.
And this seems like this has been pushed to them
all their lives, so whatever you guys desire, I mean.
I want to help them.
Oh, I'm helping them.
I don't give a fuck.
I'm resourceful.
In.
[LAUGHS]
OK.
Bob, I just-- I'll give you this--
this is the chief.
I'm asking.
Like, you may go after--
Oh, he's an author.
Man, look.
One, if we even think logically, we don't have our ship,
the only chance we have is getting out of here,
is getting our ship back, and we need to get it from those guys.
But even if we're not thinking about that,
these guys, they aren't the best.
Bob, did you ever confirm our ship was gone?
No, he never sent.
I have relied back.
It's too far for me to send Marlene.
I was just right over there.
Marlene already flew here once.
Marlene, that is no one here.
And what?
Hey, Marlene, go check it out.
No, it's way above the range of your fucking thing, bro.
Come on.
It's more-- it's farther than 100 feet, right?
OK.
Now, you also see a map of the capital, not the whole kingdom,
but just the capital.
My god, the capital map has gone to.
Fuck me.
I swear to god, I don't know how this happens.
Where is the bathroom see?
This pisses me off the knowing.
Fuck it.
Bro, I'm carrying it.
It's basically the map shows the gate.
It shows us a section that's just marked as slums.
The center area, it says, is a bit lifted up.
It's not on the same level as the slums.
And it's marked the noble district.
And there's a center building marked in the map.
And that's where the arrows are pointing at.
And the elder, basically, is still is very disappointed in him.
And he's just riding a bunch of shit.
How dare you?
You shouldn't be bringing strangers into the council.
The council will decide what happens to these guys now.
And you don't have the right to interfere
with commoner business, you've sinned.
And stuff like that is riding on it anymore.
At this point, Riff just takes the chalk out of the elder's hand.
It goes, you know, cadence has been gone for about a week, right?
We have to get her back.
She's our only hope to getting those goddamn masks off.
You understand?
We need manpower.
And any of these people cannot fight.
The only chance we have is these people have seen them fight.
They can handle themselves.
Either that or we die here fighting this useless war.
This has happened over and over again.
Every hundred years or so, you commoners think
that you can just take him down with just you.
Riff, the same house, tried to do it once.
They failed and look at where we are now.
I don't even, I am not even welcomed into my own house now.
I'm doing this for Tade and cadence.
Just believe this, that I will do anything in my power to get her back.
I don't care about your stupid fucking rebellion, old man.
And he just leaves him.
He walks off, he does not answer you.
He just, at this point where mad, he goes and talks to a bunch of like commoner people
armed here.
The old man at this point tries to like hand sign.
Any of you know hand sign, Bob.
No, I don't think so.
Hansen, wasn't there a spell?
It's comprehend languages, but I have to, I have to hear it.
It's spoken language.
Does it say?
If you tell me that I can understand hand sign with comprehend languages, I'm happy to
do so.
No, no, no, let me check.
You understand the literally meaning of an entity here or C signed.
It goes here.
It says here, bro.
Okay, so he's signing something to all of you, but none of you probably get it.
Bob, you do get it.
I'm going to send you it in the DMs.
Oh, there it is.
He also needs to cost the spell first.
Yeah.
Okay, as you see him starting to sign, you can prepare yourself essentially for one minute
and then you can start hearing it.
So I'm going to say what he's going to say for one minute and then I'm going to send
you the next one minute that he's going off.
Attention.
Bob is going to take us to equipment and say, wait, whoa, wait, wait, I have some stuff
to do and get some visors on and stuff.
He stops midway as he's signing and he nods his head as he sits down in one of these
boxes.
Can I inspect the plants that they have on the board or at least?
Okay.
In the plants, there's like a tunnel that they dug using like all the manpower they have
through this place that leads up to the center of the island and the center of the island.
It's written as the channel and supposedly it's pointing up and it goes up all the way
towards the noble district and after that the plants that are essentially like just a bunch
of scribbling that doesn't really make sense to you.
All right.
He's going to call you over.
Hey, guy in the robe.
Can you come over here?
I'm looking for a friend of mine.
Yeah, it's like who's going all of them?
The white, okay.
The small one.
I'll walk over.
As you walk over, he kind of points you to sit down right beside him on the floor.
As he sits down, he goes.
So are you joining this resistance?
Have you been calling that?
These are what we can't define how sing was.
We heard that you guys were most amicable with the combination and after seeing what's
going on in this island.
We wanted to help the people.
Amicable.
Right.
You see people like very weirdly giving him crazy eyes kind of.
All the people like commoners surrounding him.
No one is going near him.
It just got a little way as soon as he looks at them.
They just turned their heads too.
You know, all the other houses hate us for doing what we did.
And the commoners hate us because we are the deliverer or bad news.
Anytime an execution needs to be announced, the sand has to do it.
In time, taxes have to be raised.
The sand has to do it.
The reason I left my fucking family.
A bunch of cowards saying they're noble houses.
They're no better than these commoners.
Our voices have been taken away anyway.
One thing I have with me is cadence and this guitar.
I'll be damned if I let them take it away from me again.
Who is cadence?
She's my friend.
My only friend.
She went on a mission with Kira a couple days ago.
Kira got captured.
Cadence apparently also probably has been captured.
I haven't heard from them.
I'm not Kira, but maybe shed some light.
But from your accord, she's just gone.
I shouldn't have trusted an outsider.
I honestly don't know why I'm trusting you either.
But you know all I have, and I need to get cadence back.
Well, I think we have a lot of goals.
So, if we can be in those assistants, I think we can be in those assistants.
All right.
Well, let me at least tell you what the fuck this island is.
At least you'll be ready to handle what's coming to you.
Do you want to call the rest of them over?
What are we doing, Bob?
Bob Teased.
Yeah.
Oh, shit.
We got to take care of those bodies.
Come on.
Bob, it's me and you.
OK, you're going to take the bodies, and I guess then,
Baptiste is on the only one listening to Riffs thing then.
Right?
Pretty much here.
OK, Bob, by this time, you should be
able to do your comprehend languages, whatever.
All right, old man, I'm ready.
Get it, me.
The young man looks at you.
He sighs again, shakes his head.
And he starts to signal and goes, I'm happy I can listen to this.
What?
Why?
God, dammit.
I can't even do no.
You're trying to help you, right?
Bob, just so you know, and no one else can hear what you say.
Oh, yeah.
That makes sense.
I'm going to talk to you in the DMs then.
No, no, no.
You don't have to sign.
You can just--
Yeah, just so that--
So you can repeat it.
Yeah, you can repeat what they're saying.
What he's saying.
Yeah, nobody's listening, so I'm just not repeating it.
I guess, I guess, I can.
Yeah, you can say whatever you want to them.
I'm not saying you can't say anything.
It's just that the arrest don't hear anything.
OK.
All right, well, that's all he says.
And he gets up and he just goes away.
So the rest of you, Tigo, basically,
ask you what did he say?
Well, the commerce don't really agree with the noble.
They don't think he is one of them,
but he's just trying to help, I think.
They really don't want our help.
I guess we leave it up to the captain.
Power is gotten--
What do we do?
I don't know.
Do you not listen to your captain usually?
Just go with what he says.
This is busy.
You know what I'm just going to help the other guy?
I was going to go and help Roeman Malthus.
OK, what are you doing with the water?
Is I don't understand what he's doing?
We're certain.
We got to kill him first.
And then we got to--
They're spies.
They have nothing except for their weapons.
They have nothing on them, except for the whistles.
Yeah, that's about it.
Well, that's what I'm saying.
I want to see if there's different whistles.
No, there's only one type of whistle on them.
Just the big ass one, the--
Yeah.
Hey, Malthus, should we take one of these whistles?
You build a blowdark?
What about you, Tigo?
I'm just saying, we take some of this stuff.
Like, we get in trouble.
We blow that whistle or like, we have a little like.
We part of the resistance.
Roeman?
We try that.
Roeman, you're normal.
Roeman is much louder than the whistle.
Yeah, at this point, you shouldn't be worried,
because all of this place is just lined up with like,
bedrooms and everything to make like, as less sound
go out as possible.
OK, well, I'm just saying--
I'm just saying, guys, if we made it around,
we might need a distraction.
Like, we can send a little kid with the whistle.
You go blow it.
We resist all of this now.
Who's supposed to alert the enemies?
Exactly.
You get a little kid in a far off section of town blowing
this whistle.
They can enemy-- it's going to draw all the enemies to that whistle.
You get what I'm saying.
And then we stick into wherever we got to go.
We part of resistance all of this now.
I'm not going to lie.
That was the smartest thing Roeman ever said.
[LAUGHS]
I'm just saying, if we need to sneak in anywhere, like,
mouth and take one of these whistles.
Yes, let's take one of them.
OK.
So you all three have two whistles.
Who's going to take the whistles?
I'm just giving mouth and one whistle.
Oh, no, we're going to take three.
Because over again, I have multiple children.
You can't--
you can't have multiple-- they only have two on them.
You took two with you.
That's twice as many.
You're really good.
I know.
You're too bad.
OK.
I can make my own whistle.
Roeman, you take one.
I guess as your guys are discussing the whistle part,
Earth will tell Baptiste everything.
And he will also ask the name of everyone in your crew, Baptiste.
So what do you go by?
Baptiste.
And what about the rest?
Hope you have the loud beast.
That's Roma.
You could say the obese.
Oh, fuck.
Your beast beast.
[LAUGHTER]
The loud one is Roma.
OK.
Go ahead.
No one looks similar to me.
That's my face.
The office got it.
Oh, here it was.
One that doesn't look as useful as far.
Now you mean the one with the metal arm?
I don't know who that is.
Yes.
OK.
Gotcha.
What about the guy with the gauntlet?
What are they?
Tiger boy?
OK.
That's OK.
Gotcha.
T-Gore.
Got it.
All right.
Well, let me tell you what the people structure is.
At the top, we have the emperor.
There you go.
He writes it down on a piece of paper.
The emperor is allowed to do anything, as you might know already,
from multiple monarchies.
I don't know if you have those outside of this fucking island.
Then we have the high nobles, the fortress.
They're allowed to be obnoxious, I guess.
Then we have the guards.
The guards for each house are different.
The ones that you just fought are echo spies from House
Echo.
The ones at the gates are Mezos, the Mezo troop.
They are the foot soldiers for a house tremor.
And then we have House Anthem, probably one of the more
closer houses to the emperor himself.
There was a loyalist in the last battle in Forcers
where the tremors and the spies, as you might have guessed,
were the echoes.
Us, we were the ones who caused the last rebellion.
So now we are called House Sin.
We don't even know what our house was called before.
But nonetheless, House Anthem has probably
the most elite soldiers.
So we should try not to get in their way as much as possible.
So the deal with the enemy might have guessed the commoners
are not supposed to speak.
The emperor has a power that essentially lets him make
anyone obey anything as long as you can hear them.
But this power wasn't always with the emperor.
It was a commoner who had this power before.
And while the emperor killed him, and he supposedly
got the power somehow.
Now he rules for the Nine Fists, and he
only trusts his nobles.
To, I guess, do whatever they want.
The decibel decree was established some under years ago.
But the revolution has been going on for far longer.
This joke of the revolution has been going on for about five
years.
That's all.
[INAUDIBLE]
What?
Oh, yeah.
The plan.
Suspension is basically me.
My house is not even--
That's a joke, right?
Well, we had one lead.
That's why cadence and Kira are sent.
Not mentioned.
I disagreed.
I said maybe I should come with, but they
were like I would call much Kira to themselves than necessary.
So cadence left with Kira.
And-- no, not quite what we are at now.
The only thing that we want out of this revolution is get
these masks off.
The emperor sleeps almost all the time.
He never wakes up.
I don't know what his deal is, but whatever his deal is,
doesn't bother us.
The-- you probably have seen the lockjaw mechanisms
are on the commoners, yes?
Correct.
OK.
Well, those lock jaws are bound to a frequency.
And apparently, there is a way to get all those jaws free.
Once that happens, we can just leave the silent.
We don't need to stay here.
And well, I just want to leave with cadence.
I don't really care for these people,
but cadence cares, so I care.
So well, cadence found a way to get inside the broadcast
tower, get up to the top floor, and essentially
change the frequencies of the lock jaws
will be freed, and then we can leave.
The gods were taken island.
Apparently, these are the ones that explode if you go too far away.
So none of the people that live in the outskirts of the island
ever come here, because they know that they'd be just
put into the lock jaws and never let go.
So the population of this place keeps increasing.
And well, your foes to live in slums?
Well, they are foes to live in slums.
That was the plan that cadence got caught,
so we got to rescue her.
Best clue that I have at this point is she's probably
somewhere in the northern district.
So we get there, I suppose.
Since you're more accustomed to this island,
I guess we'll follow your lead.
But I do have one question.
Go ahead.
It's for brilliant.
If, as you say, you can just leave afterwards.
After everything is set and done.
What's preventing anything from happening once you do leave?
Nothing.
Or do you even keep anything?
Look, what we're hoping for is doing this stealthily.
So no one knows.
The broadcast signal cannot be listened to.
Only the commoners will know that this happened,
unless some guard is beating down some poor old woman
down the street, which is rare to happen when it happens,
fortunately, but that can't be held.
Wherever we can find, we will guide through these tunnels
and get out.
And that's our only hope to get out of this place.
How do you plan to get all these commoners out?
You have the ships?
We have ships.
Kira acquired some a while ago.
I don't know how.
That's what she told me.
That's what she left for.
Not yet enough.
You're coming with us after this, bro.
I love that riff.
Come on.
Hit it with me one time.
Give it to me one time.
As you guys are talking, you see you here.
Basically, Tom is coming from on top of the roof.
It's a sand from the roof drops down and hits you guys.
And the bedrooms start to shake.
Some of them fall off.
Just dump, dump, like someone walking on top.
Then you just hear a crack on the wall
and right in the center around here, opening opens up.
And--
Now if this wrong way.
Yep.
The massive voice amplifies from above the streets,
shaking the cave supports, and the rest of this whole area
just collapses.
Not you guys.
It does not really get on you, but this whole place
is collapsing.
As the place collapses, a massive figure just
drops down from on top.
And you can see this one is wearing a big metal armor.
And on his side, you see these sound microphones or something.
And in his hand, he's grabbing this two-pronged hammer
that's shaped like a tuning fork.
And this guy is even bigger than you,
mouth is about like a foot taller than you.
He drops down.
You see a couple of other people repel down right beside him.
And--
Awesome music.
Bob, take more.
These people just start to like gun down anyone that is in their way.
And you see that these guns that whatever projectiles they're firing
are not really making any sounds.
As one of those bullets bounces off one of these people,
and it's you, Bob.
You see that it's made of rubber.
Oh, yeah, I'm going to tell people that.
Guys, don't worry.
These guys can do shit.
It's just rubber bullets.
As this huge dude just comes in, he looks at all of the soldiers
surrounding him.
He goes, mezzos.
Gather these rats around.
Execute them if you can.
And let's quell down this rebellion, shall we?
As he starts walking up to you, Malfa says
you're the only big figure around here.
Can you guys roll for initiative?
OK, you put me in the map, maybe.
You're not on the map?
What?
Oh, I'm still in the map.
I'm still in the map.
OK.
You guys in?
I've been--
I've been fucking rafting all this time,
and no one would ever see the maps.
Oh god, dammit.
Oh, my god.
I'm fucking out.
See, you said something about the map not working,
so I just assumed we--
Oh, I see, I see, I see.
Well, the walls are not working.
You know, the shadows and everything,
they're not working here.
Anyway, well, it worked fine for me then.
Bob and Tegor, y'all, handle, y'all,
protectors, commoners.
All right.
My Roma, can you initiative?
I'm on there.
I'm on there, twice.
Oh, where?
I don't know.
Oh, I see, I see, I see.
Why do we have to rob us?
I don't know.
All right.
It's Bob, your turn.
As you see these people jump in, what do you want to do?
All of the people are around here.
All of this area is basically filled with people.
Wait, where exactly are the people?
Every--
I'm from the--
Bro.
I sure got-- all of this area, this, this, this,
this, every place is filled except for where they landed.
All right.
That's bad.
Oh, my God.
That's not bad.
That's so bad.
This is so bad.
All right.
So do I have to initially make a save as well?
Yes.
The debt savings initial, the rest are strength saves.
Oh, my God.
Main guy failed?
No.
Not a deal.
Oh, God.
Oh, baby.
Two pay all.
Two succeed.
What's my port and again?
Did I use it?
When you got a rope with a big guy, you got--
Oh, my God.
Jesus Christ.
I swear to God, I'm going to--
Why is this token not--
Oh, God.
Okay.
No, that's great.
He's token is gone.
Jesus fucking Christ.
Well, here's never existed.
Yeah.
You're a DM.
You know you're not my DM.
What is that?
I'm going to-- I'm going to-- I can lose it.
It's okay.
I'm going to lose it.
Don't lose it, DM.
Give me one second.
I'll get the token ready and then I'll
do the rolls manually.
This is why I never should have fucking gone to the Pokemon
thing.
Jesus Christ.
Pokemon.
Yeah, I was doing the Pokemon one-shot preparations
and I switched the thing and then everything's gone.
Woofer.
There we go.
All right.
Oh, my God.
Sword.
God, bro.
His name is Sword God.
Woofer.
You don't know that.
What do you care?
All right.
Let me do a tech save.
I swear.
I had his--
Fail.
You know what?
I have his--
Okay, okay.
It might not be that bad because I have the--
No, I don't.
Oh, God damn it.
First circle.
Fail.
Okay.
I have this roll for this guy and that's basically him.
No, what?
[laughter]
There we go.
Yeah, he's gonna save.
No.
Two of them failed.
Two of them saved.
And the big guy is just not affected.
He just grabs his--
the camera thing and he just wats it away.
All the web.
All right.
It's--
Malphus.
Yeah.
Go ahead.
[laughter]
What do we do?
We will.
[laughter]
They're not work.
Just click Transform.
You don't need to do anything.
I can't.
Oh, God.
Transform.
There you go.
[inaudible]
What do I have 44 temp HP?
Is it not 44?
Is it less?
I think it's 16, right?
Yeah, it's level times 4.
Yeah, it's--
Okay.
There you go.
Do you have 28 HP?
Yeah, because I was the only one taking damage that's fine.
Oh, yeah.
[inaudible]
Wait.
Now, what are you doing?
Uh...
Doing a shutter.
Okay.
You walk up to him.
How do you shatter?
Explain how your shutter works.
[inaudible]
Right.
Uh, like as the...
My wings from my back just like go over to my arms and just...
Mm-hmm.
Kind of merge into the hybrid.
Oh, yeah.
Just stomp a fist on the floor and...
Cut off.
Oh, cool, cool, cool.
All right.
Two of them will take damage.
One of them saves...
Probably will still take damage, but...
One of them saves.
Yeah, half damage.
Uh...
And...
Oh, god.
What was it?
Constitution, right?
Yeah.
That's a decent roll.
Yeah, his armor becomes a bit unstable as you just hit the ground.
And he just takes a big, like, drop as he goes down and falls on its back.
All right.
Roll the damage.
What was it?
Uh...
Nine?
18.
Oh, that's the safe damage is nine, right?
Uh, yeah.
Uh...
Okay.
Why is it not doing the...
Okay, mesotropes.
There we go.
I think it was you apply.
And then...
You apply.
And then this guy...
Apply.
Let me add him here and...
Oh, goddammit.
It's like so.
6749.
Okay.
[silence]
All right.
As these guys just fall down, I think two of them don't take any damage, right?
Oh, my god.
I'm all over the place today.
Old-tea damage to safety, health damage.
Yeah.
Uh...
What was it?
18?
Holy shit.
Yeah, these guys will just immediately fall down.
And they're knocked out.
I mean, that works.
Yeah.
And the other two are barely standing.
You just see these shock waves as the rocks also fall onto them.
As they're going down, the shaking just caused all the rocks to also fall on them.
Uh, all right.
That's your move, I think.
Two of them are still up.
These two are still up.
Which two?
These two, these two.
The two on the front.
Yeah, two in the back.
Also Bob, why didn't you move?
Is the big me instill up?
Yeah.
Okay, I just want to make sure.
If he went down from one attack, that'd be pretty.
Yeah.
Just gonna go to stay there for a little while.
Yep, that's me.
Oh no.
I'm gonna do a fun show about these guys with the Xs.
Right.
This guy takes his rifle and he's just going to point at you.
Malthus and you're just going to start shooting.
I'm in the center of everything.
By the way, if you want to move here, you have to make the deck save.
Or I can just float over.
You can't just like hover over if you want to.
I thought we were in a secluded area.
Like a hallway.
What?
What are you saying?
I like you saying that other things were inside the webs on the ceiling and everything.
The webs.
No, no, I think it's like isn't webs just on the floor or does it cover everything?
I think it's only on the floor.
Only on the floor.
Yeah.
All right.
This one will hit you for five.
No, no, that's the second one.
The first one did hit.
It's just a fucking every time I roll it.
I mean, just the existing one.
What the fuck is wrong with foundry?
I don't know.
I can't figure it out.
How much does it have to make?
I think it's five.
Well, I succeed.
I don't know if there is no reaction.
As it flies to you, you just water way.
Next is under this robot or something?
He's behind him.
Jesus Christ.
The shadow can go away, right?
The shadow area.
But what I'm saying though is it's a 20 foot cube for web.
So like, my office would still have to make the save if he's flying into the cube.
Let me read, actually.
Do any cool cube there for durations?
Well, there you go.
Nothas make you safe.
Dex?
Yeah, it's a dex.
And then strength to get out.
Yeah, yeah, you're fine.
All right.
That piece, your turn.
You see?
Already?
Yeah.
You're so big.
Wow.
Okay.
That's a time.
I'm moving up.
Thank you.
Yeah.
I'm going to pop my arms of ash or cell.
That should hit all three of them.
What does that just do?
Oh, that's your nice.
Yeah, I'm applying the arms of Esersault to you.
Sorry.
What was it, Dex, right?
Yes.
Okay.
The guy succeeds.
I really want to take them.
And the other two also succeed, I think, yeah.
No, no.
The boss I rolled incorrectly.
Yeah, no one failed.
So what was that to at the beginning?
Yeah, that's the token for like this guy, but this guy does not have his stats.
Another guy, the berserker, that has a stats.
No, no.
Wow.
As your arms of complete void start to show up around you, the guy just looks at you.
Little rat, you're the one that broke the king's gate.
Well, you're going to pay for that.
You don't get to call me a rat.
All right, go ahead.
18 minutes.
Yes.
Oh, also you were right.
All right, as you take your fist and just basically jamming a jamming inside one of those
like speaker things right around his shoulders as you know what, I'm fucking removing this web.
You can't even see what the fuck's happening.
Yes, I have no idea where mouth of it.
I'm behind the big guy.
Yeah, there we go.
I am the big guy.
I'm going to remove all of these like fucking placement things.
Don't do anything.
Just obstruct your will.
All right, as you just punch straight through his armor, one of the speakers just goes off.
And yeah, you hit him for 11.
What the fuck man?
I just don't understand how this damaging thing works.
It's so confusing now.
Let me just place damage.
There we go.
All right, the fist just goes in and just hits him right in the shoulders.
As you grab one of its arm, you know that the person inside is not as big as the armor.
So this is a type shit.
Yeah.
That's a lot of things.
At this point, the rift's going to come running up.
He goes fucking tremors.
Woofer.
How is it going?
Now, let's put your two rest finally.
He's going to do.
You know this guy.
A riff on his, unfortunately, I do.
He riffs on the guitar and then he just turns it around, flips it and shoots it with the rifle on the end.
Oh, he's like the hell is it?
He's a saffron or a circle replacement.
There you go.
As the bullets just essentially a rubber bullets just spread right on the metal body.
It doesn't even make a dent, but the shock waves from the bullets just essentially just stun him for a second.
All right, that's going to be his move.
T-Gore.
What do you want T-Gore to do?
T-Gore's going to just run up.
Jump.
Yeah.
And he points at everyone around and he goes, right to the tunnel then.
He saw the maps probably and he's asking them to move to the tunnel.
And he's rounding up all the people to leave.
It's going to be this guy and this guy is trying to go and hit T-Gore.
Wait, is there any restraint?
Who are restraints?
But yeah, he can still shoot.
Disadvant.
Right?
No, no, no, no, no, this is an advantage on melee.
Or a 10, that does hit him.
And seven.
Yeah, the second one does not hit.
As one of the shots go right into T-Gore's back, he will take seven damage.
As he reels from it, he grabs the old man and he just tries to get him out of danger.
All right, Ramos, your turn.
Oh, she's...
What were you talking about?
Oh, you know, I'm gonna...
I'm fucking running up.
Big deal right there.
I'm fucking...
As I'm running, I'm yelling, "I'm resistance!"
See, now it's working.
Now it says rage.
Okay, go ahead.
Yeah.
Um, we're... now I gotta do my fucking attack.
Rage doesn't give me an advantage to...
No, reckless does.
You can go reckless.
Thank you, that's what it is.
I'm like trying to find reckless, but like...
All right, apply a fix.
Yeah?
It's not letting me.
Yeah, it is applying.
Okay.
Go ahead.
Attack.
Oh my god.
That's that one and the three.
Okay, as you try to swing your skillet on its body,
it just blocks it with the tuning fork hammer.
I just deflects it.
All right, next is...
Bob.
Bob?
Okay, how are we, Smalfers?
Behind the big guy.
You know what?
You're fucking...
No, I don't...
Yeah, I don't know what to steal.
Because the web is there and I don't want to get Malfa's inter-truvel.
Okay.
Everyone is around the web, so just be sure everyone's gonna get hit.
Yeah, it's a problem.
I wanted to burn the web.
Yeah, I know what you were trying to do.
Maybe try to communicate with the team first.
You know what? It says that any five feet that gets into fire will start burning.
So if our position is away, then that part of the web will not burn, right?
What?
What are you trying to do?
Okay, I'm gonna explain this to you as...
It's amicably responsible.
If you fire the web, the rest of the shit is going to catch on fire.
There are wood boxes, there are wood tables.
Everything is very flammable.
Just so you know...
Yeah, it's a primitive island.
They're not industrial islands.
Every single thing I can do is fire.
Okay, you know what? I'm just gonna shoot.
Yeah.
What I told you to do Bob, protect the citizens.
Who are you shooting at?
Any one of these guys that are blood-aid?
Yeah, this guy.
Fuck it, Andy.
Yeah, he fails.
Don't rule the damage.
Bob, you want this armor after this fight?
Well, you broke like half the shoulder.
I don't know how secure it is.
Yeah, this guy goes down as soon as your bullet hits his head.
He just drops straight down.
Is there any place where are the people again?
Are they out from the tunnel?
No, they're running this way.
All of them.
All of the people from here, but all the people from here are still here.
I don't see your pointer, so I have no idea what you're talking about.
You're here.
Why are you doing Baptiste's pointer?
Baptiste is doing Baptiste's pointer.
Then they can't go.
Then there is no place to go.
I'll just stay over here.
Math is your turn.
Just hit him.
Okay.
The bandage.
Okay, the damage.
No, my God.
Really quickly.
Oh, my God.
Why does it keep doing that?
Have you targeted yourself?
What?
I was selected.
As your claws go right into him, like through the gap in his neck,
the burst of electricity just hits his body as he kind of freezes for a second.
It's going to be this soldier who's still alive.
Okay, sorry.
Go ahead.
Another one.
That's right.
I bet.
Okay.
That's going to hit.
Yeah.
What?
Do you have the big guy in the initiative?
I do.
Oh, wait, no.
Wait, he was.
He was the initiative.
I think he was after mouth as I think, right?
Oh, he did not do anything this whole fight down.
I'm going to just take his axe and just swing.
I could have not said anything and just let us keep on.
Yeah.
So that 10 hits him.
And let me see.
Okay.
He takes his tuning fork and he just starts pounding with the reckless.
So it's going to be advantage.
An edge.
23.
And a crit.
So let me roll the crit damage first.
What are you hitting?
I'm going to roll a 1D4 because he's at this point just panicking and he just trying to hit anyone in his range.
Including this guy, by the way.
So 1, 2, 3, 4.
Oh, 1D4.
It's Roma.
You're getting hit for 20.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Slashing resistance.
He's not slashing though.
He's blushing.
No, no, he's not slashing.
He's using the tuning fork.
Turing fork is not slashing.
Is he slashing and blushing?
It is blushing.
It is also half dead.
Cool.
All right.
He swings his tuning fork and just hits you.
First, that connects right with your face.
The other hit will, let me roll it again.
2012 plus 3.
It's going to be another 8.
And that's half.
It's going to be 4.
Yeah.
Okay, yes.
So the first time he bashes you as soon as it connects to you, he tries to hit you again.
But that one does not connect right to your face.
It's blocked by your arm.
All right.
I'm going to go ahead and do it once more because I think it's his turn again.
19.
That will head and...
Oh, I think I have to do it twice to hit it twice.
Okay.
Makes sense.
16.
Okay.
I'm going to roll 1D4 again.
It's going to target you, Baptiste, this time.
So first one heads, right?
19.
Maybe.
And 16.
16 misses.
Okay.
The first one is bludgeoning.
So that's going to do half, right?
Oh, no, no, you're not on your...
Okay.
It's going to do full.
He strikes Roma twice and turns around and then hits you again.
I'm going to have to get a hook and you're going to attack me.
The dice man, I can't do anything about it.
All right.
It's his turn.
Okay, Baptiste, your turn again.
I'm taking my revenge.
Hopefully.
Oh, my God.
That's hot.
Yeah, that will hit.
That's 18.
One more.
That will hit.
What's up?
Okay, how do you want to finish him off?
Jesus.
I want one of my actual arms, the go into it's speaker.
Uh-huh.
Making a loud noise that just explodes the arm.
Okay.
Makes him bleed from his ears.
Any rips out.
Applaia junior.
All right.
As you jump up on him, you don't even do anything.
One of your actual arms goes right inside one of the other who first on the other shoulder.
And just burst it.
The flame goes off his mask.
The helmet just pops off.
And you see as his ears starts to ring and it starts to bleed.
And he just drops down face first onto the ground.
And that kills him.
You were trying to kill him, right?
He's smaller than these soldiers.
Well, rips said at the beginning of fight time to put you to rest.
So I'm assuming I'm going to kill him.
Okay.
All right.
Uh-uh.
One of the soldiers is still alive.
Or says, okay, capture this one.
And I guess at this point, he'll just drop his weapons in surrender.
And then he'll just drop his weapons in surrender.
No, they were probably one heads probably.
Most of you could just knock them off in one head.
Uh-uh.
Oh, yeah.
There's a lot of guys, but one big guy.
All right.
Yeah.
It's nice.
There it is.
Yeah.
Is there anything in there, buddy?
Mm-hmm.
I told you, like these, these islands, this normal, like fucking sly islands,
they're not enough of a threat.
All right.
Is there anything in their bodies?
Under bodies, you don't really find much except for like, again,
the same type of bells that you found on the other bodies,
but this time there's two.
One that the guard rang at the front gate,
and then another one with like special shape, like the one that you got from the Echo Spice.
On the body, they just have their weapons, and that's it, tactical stuff.
We have four bells.
Whittle.
Mm-hmm.
God.
Yeah, yeah, you do have four bells, bro.
Bob.
Bob, you gotta grab these rape whistles, bro.
I can't carry them.
I already got two last five.
I mean, I can make whistleblows by myself, but okay.
Well, this is just okay.
Just okay.
Okay.
Can I pick up a giant tuning fork and see if it would be any useful?
I mean, you can try to-- can you do strength?
It's way big.
Yeah, let me-- I got you.
You just want to just drink--
Just straight strength, yeah.
No, no, no, you can't.
You need an 18-in-hire.
Yeah, as you try to lift it, you can move it around, but it's not viable as a weapon.
If you want to, you can use it, but it's going to be with disadvantage every time.
I mean, technically, Roma's pan does more damage than this one.
That's what--
If I could connect, I'm just saying, but like last fight, I swung a myth.
Every fucking time?
No.
All right.
On his-- as you are searching their bodies, can everyone in the range, which is Malthus,
Baptiste, Roma, Bob, and this guy?
Can everyone make a-- yeah, except for Tegor.
Tegor is far.
Make a-- Dex safe?
Oh, you're going to shatter a fucking hero's drums, aren't you?
Oh, no.
Yeah, it refails.
Who?
12, 9, 22.
Malthus, you are the only one who is able to detect like the rumbling on top,
so you should be able to jump back and get away while the rocks just fall on these guys.
You guys take a total of 2-10 damage.
Yes.
What kind of damage?
No, no, no, no, you-- at this point, you're probably--
I'd say you're a bit far away.
Just bludgeoning.
So it would be half, right?
Yeah.
So it's not that deep.
Oh, it's just four.
Damn, four-- that's two.
It's like the rocket's here in the head.
Yeah.
Would I still be raging, because literally the fight just ended?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You would be raising.
So you take 2 damage.
Everyone else takes 4.
So let damage--
let's damage.
And Malthus, you should be able to get away from there before the collapse happens.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, so they don't get hit by the debris.
All right, ask.
Yeah, at this point, you can safely say like none of the other parts of the cave are collapsing at this point
because the walls are holding still.
But you are now quite right in the open.
And you have some kind of evacuate.
Riff goes up to you, Baptiste, well, it seems like we have to move up our plants.
Okay, I'll talk to the old man, get these people to evacuate to into the tunnel, seal them off somehow.
So they don't find us again.
But yeah, we need to get moving with the plan, I guess.
Or do you need us?
All right, just hold on a second.
He goes up to the old man.
He signs some stuff to him.
He takes all the people around, gathers them, and they start to leave through a corner crate.
They move the crate away, and they start to leave through that opening from there.
And you see a bunch of people just following the old guy through.
Now in the ruins is just you and this guy who's still alive, rest of them are dead.
This guy who's just hands up just still around waiting around.
Riff left with them?
What?
The riff left with them with those people?
No, he just talks about the old man.
No, no, he just talked to the old man.
He's still around.
And he grabs two of those spies that you knocked out and just slaps them away.
And now you have three people to interrogate.
When they started interrogating, I'm going to cut magic on the first one.
Sorry to take on.
All right.
Which one?
The spies or this guy?
No, no, no, the spies were different than that you grabbed from up there.
Okay, which one looks like you would give me more information?
Which one looks a bit more?
I don't know, smart.
Well, it would be the spies.
I mean, I'm telling you right now, I think you have enough intelligence to do.
I have enough intelligence to tell that the spies would have more information than the normal foot soldiers.
Oh, we have the spies as well.
No, you were just grabbing them.
Nothing happened really with the spies.
I just saw you people murdering people, so I thought everyone was dead.
Should be used to that by now, Bob.
If a head's up to the spies and just slaps them awake, as soon as he slaps them awake, the spies bite something in their mouth.
And he just goes, well, that makes my job easier.
And they just start frothing in the face and they die essentially.
They probably bit something like a pill or something.
Two of them at the same time.
And you cast the magic on the spy, so it's not going to work on the other ones.
Anyway, so the other guy that was just the troop, he dropped his weapons and Riff has him there.
And he looks back, he goes, I'm not really good at this stuff.
And he helped here.
Give me a second.
Anything, anyone but him, please.
Okay, I'm leaving.
He does not really leave, he just gets away.
Go ahead, Roman.
You got it, Roman.
All right, big dog.
How do you know we were here?
I'm like cracking my knuckle.
Like, you know, like, do the stretch like the old man.
I heard the whistle.
I'll see you think.
Again, you can't cast it.
You already cast it on the other two.
I got those locks.
It takes a while.
It's not like you can just magically do it.
One minute.
Big dog, come on now, that whistle from the from across the way.
Wait, is it one minute time or one minute action?
Oh, it's yours.
Okay, you can cast it.
Cast it twice.
Come on, big dog.
Come on.
Let me do a wisdom safe first to see if.
The wisdom is only when I'm probing deeper.
Okay, okay.
Well, you can't probe deeper just in case.
All right.
So what do you ask, Roma?
I was like, the whistle was when we were across the street.
You guys want to went over there.
How do you know we were in this building?
Come on, brother.
Do you think we're stupid?
Does he think you're stupid?
Okay, as you slap, as you try to slap the shit out of him,
riff will grab your hand and go, okay, it's not how interrogation goes.
He's giving us answers when he doesn't give us answers.
Then you slap him.
No, he ain't giving us shit.
I'm slapping the shit out of him.
Okay, go ahead, do damage.
What would it be?
Just like strength.
Just what's your strength modify?
Just tell me that.
Plus three.
Now, I told you to not do that.
No, he got it.
Waged for him to go.
No, we don't have the time.
Now go, go get some water.
Come on, riff.
I got you.
Jesus Christ.
He grabs one of these barrels.
He takes a small cup from one of the cupboards.
He takes out the water in that and he throws it on his face.
Now, look, just, I just need to know one thing.
Okay, shut up for a second.
Okay, I just need to know one.
Oh my god, I'm leaving.
He leaves.
No, just, riff.
Come back.
I got you big dog.
Because you know what?
You're going to be the one who's going to answer the question now when he wakes up.
You wake up.
You woke up.
I'm the worst.
All right.
No, don't risk it.
Tell you a question.
How do you handle this guy looks at you Bob?
This is what we're going to do.
You will do.
You will get used to it.
Okay.
That's your question.
riff.
Okay.
Now, tell me.
Do you know where this girl is?
He takes out like a hand drawn like picture of cadence and he points it to the guy's face.
The guy kind of looks at it.
Does anyone want to do an insight who's in there?
Answer his question.
You're both gay.
Yeah, he definitely seems to recognize who she is.
Baptist.
You know that.
You can see in his eyes that he recognizes the picture.
But you're too far away.
So you can't say anything.
I didn't realize they moved.
No, okay.
All right.
Roma adds you're trying to say he just nods his head now.
I don't know who she is.
All right.
All right, brother.
I'm going to have to slap you again.
Okay, okay, okay.
I don't just fucking stop.
I know where she is.
She's in the opera house.
See, Rift.
See how it's done.
She just ignores you at this point.
He just grabs him.
He goes where in the opera house.
She with the lady.
So far.
He nods kind of.
Yes.
God damn it.
He throws him down.
He gets up.
He goes, well, we don't have much time.
She's probably going to just kill her at some point.
So just follow me.
And you.
He takes out his gun.
And he just points it like straight up to his head.
And he just turns around his guitar and just max him in the head instead of just shooting.
And knocks him out.
Hey, hold on.
Hold on, bro.
I'm sorry.
We ain't got much time.
I got to make sure.
I got to make sure home is all right.
You know what I'm saying?
Give me give me give me a couple of seconds.
All right.
Okay.
I'm out.
You get that one.
Wait, go on is.
Let me check.
What was it?
Oh, treat.
You just drop.
You just already made me.
I'm not going to be able to do it.
You just drop.
You just already made them.
You're just giving them out.
Okay.
I'm going to get Malfa's one and I'm going to give me one.
Malfa's you can heal.
And you can heal.
There you go.
These like fish shaped chips essentially and that just pumps you up a bit.
At this point, Riff is just walking around.
He's just waiting for you guys to finish out.
Whatever you were doing.
How was already following him?
Okay.
You follow him.
Go as well.
Our plan is clear.
I guess we go to the center which climb up and we get through.
I'm just trying to make sure you do understand what.
You're walking yourself into red.
If she's in the opera house, then it's the anthems we've got to fight.
And the anthems soldiers are much tougher than these.
I mean, I'm really surprised that it took Wolfer down in like what three heads.
But it's not going to be that easy with Sofra.
Is it a way we could draw them out of the opera house?
Look, as soon as we what little kids no one's here.
We go get little kids.
Okay.
I'm just going to ignore this guy for now.
I'm talking to you about these.
As soon as we get up, just pretend to be.
It's going to be tough, but just pretend to be my silence.
I can't even say it.
Whatever.
Just pretend to be with me and we should be safe.
They may throw some rocks.
They may say some things.
You just don't have to react.
You understand?
Don't react.
We infiltrate the opera house.
We get inside.
We take cadence.
We get out.
We probably have the override disc.
Probably if they haven't gotten the location of the disc out of her yet.
Once we get the disc, our plan is good to go.
We go in the broadcast hour.
We disable the jaw locks.
That's all we have to do and we run away.
Got it.
Anyone can confuse.
He looks it.
I am.
Who are we supposed to kill in the end?
I need to know.
No one is going to kill anyone.
Do you understand me?
No one is going to kill him with this.
Is a stealth mission.
If you cannot handle your guy about these, he can stay here.
Okay.
Bro, if a stealth mission, I'm 500 pounds.
Where do you think I'm going to stealth?
Just stay with me.
Okay.
You don't have to hide around.
You just have to follow me.
I think it's like a fucking earthquake.
It's fine.
Bro, no.
I can have me.
Do you have fluffy paws?
It's okay.
Yeah.
I mean, tigers.
No, I don't like wolves.
You do have like...
It's going to be fine.
But he wears boots.
It's not like he's fucking going to rodog his feet on the ground.
I don't know what he's talking about.
All you hear is the stop of my head.
Just trust me.
Just behave like you're one of the commoners.
I'll take care of it.
Do you really have a commoner?
Is that a wolf?
We can have anything.
Doesn't matter.
This part is going to be not on the map.
So don't worry if there's no map because there's not a map.
He guides you through these mall tunnels.
You see these tunnels are like digged out by...
Anything, anything that they can grab.
They don't get access to shovels or anything.
But whatever supplies they had,
like plates, spoons, whatever.
They use those that digged this tunnels out.
And this particular tunnel leads you to like a big shaft.
And you hear like air just bursting through this one tunnel.
Again and again in like few...
Like five to ten seconds.
And as soon as you get out,
you see this giant ring of channels going out of this place.
And he points at it and goes...
We call this the channel.
Gary's fresh air to the nobles.
From their waste heat down to us.
It's the only way up to the house that Echo doesn't watch.
Be careful.
We have a long way to go up.
Every hour,
there are the Emperor's recorder announcements run.
When he speaks, the sound pressure in the tube is enough to knock you out.
So it's about 10 to 20 minutes between...
Then that broadcast...
So just climb fast, okay?
He grabs onto one of the ladders
and he starts climbing up.
Oh hell.
Bro, I'm gonna have a wave.
You say that.
I'm gonna get hit with the blast.
Paying the bail.
It might not be that bad for your mom.
I'm just gonna say.
So who's going first?
That's what I need to know.
We know who we can help who.
Because if you go last, no one can help you.
Well, except for the last person.
We all got broke.
Hit to hit.
So none of us fall.
Well, there's one disadvantage to tying each other.
I can tell.
Riff does not listen to your...
He's just in a hurry.
He just boots up.
As soon as he can, he just starts climbing up.
I'm following after a riff.
Okay.
Tegor hands you like one end of the rope and it goes...
They go Roma.
I think I'm not as strong as the other guys,
but I think I can still lift you if anything wrong happens.
And you can definitely lift me, right?
I said out.
Yeah, I don't think you can lift me, bro.
Let me check. What was his strength?
Yeah, he's not that good.
I don't know what he's saying.
I'm sorry, but sweet.
Well, I can try.
I'll need help.
And the flaggers.
Bob, the cast lavid.
Levitate.
Okay.
Levy, Oscar.
So who's getting tied up in the ropes
and who's not? Who's just going on there?
Wait, is it really hard to climb rope?
Like, why are we thinking so much about it?
Why are you so stressed?
Bro, I suck at climbing.
I'm 500 pounds.
You used to it.
You know what?
Roma, don't resist.
What don't resist?
I'm going to go to the top of the road.
Okay.
Oh, sweet Jesus.
Yeah, let's get up.
Bob, top on top of the road.
I'm just using as a carpet.
No, no, no, okay.
He's already the maximum weight I can carry with that.
Okay.
I can't believe it.
We're going down.
I'm better climbing.
So why do you stand up?
Malfa, I'm going to need you underneath to lift me up too,
which way?
Why do you stand up?
Hey Roma, that's not something you can talk about.
What?
The wings.
He's too far away to listen, you know.
But Malfa is your man.
Why did he stand up?
What?
Who's Tabas?
How wide are these panels?
Pretty wide.
Yeah, you can pretty easily like fly up if you want to.
Okay.
I'm going to make a smaller act that really...
Wait, do you have to roll to climb?
No, no, no.
You can climb.
So everyone's climbing and Roma and Tigor are tied up,
and that's it.
Yeah.
And I got...
I was cast to levitate.
Who was casting levicant?
I'm just levitating Roma up.
Okay, okay.
So no one's tied up.
Okay, cool.
Tigor.
Tigor's just like one end of the rope is tied to his...
Yeah.
Tigor's tied to his...
No, no, no.
As you're climbing up, soon enough, there's...
this pressure starting to build on top.
Maybe somewhere around like mid-away.
It's been about like maybe eight to nine minutes,
and the pressure starting to build up.
You can start to hurry up that...
for that I will need an acrobatics for each one.
Or you can just keep going at the same pace you're going.
Roma already has levitated cast on him,
so don't he get the advantage of...
Again, if you fail the acrobatics,
you will slip.
I should have probably mentioned that.
So we're doing acrobatics or no?
I did by...
Okay, I'm also...
He's so...
You're gonna slip.
Can you give me a...
That's fine.
Okay.
So you're gonna fly.
Stop yourself from falling.
Okay.
I'm slipping.
What am I supposed to let you do?
I don't think anyone would be noticing this,
because Baptiste is pretty close to Riff,
but there's a little bit of space between you guys, so...
It's not...
Noticable.
And the rest...
Are you gonna make the acrobatics or no?
Are you just climbing up at an normal pace?
I have a question.
Do I get...
Do I get advantage from side of levitate?
You're not climbing.
I'm talking about Bob.
You can't climb faster than that.
Why do I need to climb faster?
What was the acrobatics for?
What's the problem here?
Faster.
Do you wanna go faster or no?
No, I'm good.
You can go think about that.
Okay.
You don't know what.
So as the pressure starts to build up at top,
you can feel the vibrations in the chamber.
It's basically like built of brass and everything,
and you feel the vibration through the ladder, everything.
And there's gonna be a big shockwave coming towards you guys.
Either you can do a strength or you can do a wisdom.
So...
Let me know.
What do you want?
Sorry.
Athletics or perceptions.
Whichever you choose, different things are gonna happen.
But...
Yeah.
Perception.
It's better.
Perception or athletics?
I'm gonna go...
I hate to say it.
I gotta go athletics.
I suppose...
Oh yeah, that's your fucking hard magic.
All right, perception.
Baptiste or fail.
Roma.
Pass.
Bob.
Roma doesn't need to pass or fail,
because he's not doing anything.
So it's gonna hit him as it hits Bob.
Athletics.
Okay.
The shockwave comes straight to you guys.
And Malthus, you would be the first to notice that there's a pressure building.
Baptiste, you don't notice the pressure coming towards you.
You do see...
Riff in front of you just grab the ladder and he stops moving.
But you are not quick enough to like shield yourself in that way.
But the shockwave hits you.
Can you...
Well, you can't really do anything.
That's the...
You start to fall down.
But let me go to Malthus.
Malthus, you see the shockwave building up and you see the pressure starting to build up.
So you try to grab the ladder as best as possible.
Grab the ladder as best as you can so you don't slip.
Same for you, Bob and Roma, as you see that.
I'm gonna make a roll for T-Gore, which was...
Athletics, right?
There we go.
Yeah, he's gonna be fine too.
As this wave hits you, Baptiste, you start to fall.
And can anyone...
Everyone below, can you guys...
First of all, let me check something.
If this works, then it's gonna be funny.
Okay, if it's one, then Baptiste is just gonna smack into Roma.
And if it doesn't, then you're just gonna keep falling.
It's a one.
As you fall down, Baptiste, you just bounce on top of Roma.
How do you grapple them?
With my other hand, with my...
With IBDN.
Sure, make a strength check.
Okay.
Okay, DM.
I am grappling in the right...
I mean, I don't know what Bob is trying to do, but let him do what he's trying to do.
Okay, go ahead, Bob.
And Bob is augmented, so he has powerful builds, so he has advantage on...
Grabbing someone...
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, go ahead.
200 advantage.
So I will have it better.
I have a minus one, but...
No, let's see, let's see.
You can roll the zero again, who knows?
He's gonna be fine.
Is it gonna work?
15...
Should be good enough, yeah?
You grab Baptiste, but the shockwave was just the preceptor to what is about to happen.
The volume of the announcement that Emperor...
Once Emperor does make every like 40 minutes or so,
it starts to come down, the sound wave hits you again.
Can everyone make a constitution saving throw?
Yeah, it needs to stop with the wing jokes.
Not 20, baby.
Oh, I don't need you to do it, right?
Because he's not climbing.
He's not going to fall off, but the sound is not going to affect anything.
From the shockwave, you're gonna...
Roma and Malfa, you're gonna take 2d6, and that will also knock you out for a second.
So Malfa is also going to fall down.
So, you're gonna fall off.
You're gonna fall off.
again Malfus it is
a
up in the air with like rockets underneath me just pat
you're going up up up yeah next year you should be able to like support yourself with the
win with your rings fingers in my eyes while going up further. you have your carrot like pieces of carrots or something.
For what? to stick all the way up there bro? he's all the way up there are you gonna get
passed out. yeah he's passed out you will wake up in a few seconds but yeah for now you're passed out.
um okay uh Baptiste you've been grabbed by Bob and one of his his metal arms is grabbing you by the
foot uh you can grab the ladder beneath you and start to climb up again. I need a dex save from you though.
yeah that's should be good enough. okay you grab the ladder you start to climb up again. everyone is
back to consciousness. mouth as you fall a bit below uh T-Gore before like actually holding yourself
and you grab the ladder as you're flying and you start to climb up again. do you want to still
climb up or do you want to fly? straight up. how far is it? uh again you were halfway a bit
above halfway I'd say uh so well you know the times you can either start climbing normally or you can
fly up. I mean I can just go dash to the top right. yeah. oh just go to the top and see what's up there.
okay as you're climbing up what are you doing? you're just flying up or are you passing everyone?
how do you pass everyone? I mean there's still okay so you you're just flying. pass riff too?
yeah I'll stop at this height and say like oh jack up ahead.
uh okay okay he sees you fly up it's kind of confused. uh yeah
he saw me like she over the old man and people read my things right there. yeah I guess so um
all right let me move you guys to top first let me explain like what do you see when you reach the top
when you reach the top you get out in like a small alleyway and from that alleyway like essentially
like what do you call it the the manhole essentially getting out of a manhole a small manhole and as you
get out uh you see the area is very different from how it was below. everything is built with marble
white stone or some goldish hue uh sound is everywhere like everyone's talking screaming at
each other from rooftops or whatever and the nobles have like tea parties set up in their um buildings
and everything their houses uh and again on the street itself there's like people just walking
around normally uh no uh no guards nothing like unlike below uh they don't really talk they're just
screaming at each other and you see the nobles uh are wearing like these gold plated cone collars
like somehow that makes their voice even louder um and you can somewhat hear wildins and opera music
going down like this alley right in front of this alley and if you walk a bit ahead you will see a
big opera house in the center and right across from the opera house you see a giant tower
and it's glowing white uh as the rest of uh the people come from behind
mouthfuls and i'm gonna line people up before exposing the map uh there you go oh yeah uh uh
i wanted to just say to everyone i enjoyed being here night all right good night good night and before we
get up uh i'm gonna whisper to Roma dude whatever you do do not speak a word okay
i guess he got the stout okay
okay i just need to know what i'm conscious yet
no no you're not unconscious you you got to okay quick
and i'm gonna be like what
dude do not speak a word okay silence
these are my people they yelling all right uh i'm gonna say you walk up out of the alley
and uh rift at this point gets past you and he goes i'll just stay here okay
uh when i signal just start following me no uh as he gets out you guys are in
can see the map oh yeah oh okay uh okay why does this okay
uh essentially the you're walking along the building that was the opera house that uh
malphys saw initially and you walked out of this alley right here uh as uh
oh what's this face fucking rift is walking uh you see a bunch of nobles give him like a look
as one of them starts to uh walk towards rift and he goes
all right well if it isn't one of the sins walking around what happened
did they kick you out of your own house rift uh and the guy kind of peaks behind rift and looks at
all of you he goes a kind of monstrosities of you've been walking around here far
rift just looks backing he just nods his head as if like don't don't say anything and he just smiles
and goes oh if it isn't the burn himself oh um i was just getting my silenced
of walk get some maybe get them to listen to some opera you know i'll foolish
these people are he's like really trying not to hit him uh as he's gritting his teeth he's going well
well then bear maybe see each other again the bear and goes uh how wish we never see each other again
rift how is your whole house would just sort of disappear into nothingness but the emperor does not
see you fit for execution just yet anyway the taxis are being increased so maybe we'll hit one of
you guys too announce them and he laughs and walks away uh you see him just shouting to another one
lovely weather isn't it barren another another guy just starts talking to him and rift goes
oh follow me just ignore them just if they do anything just try to i don't know just just follow me
whatever we can do right now is just like don't go look like uh he starts walking
you can you guys not move we're in the line right yeah okay yeah um
uh each he starts walking he goes all right just around the corner there's a place i know that we
can enter through uh he keeps moving keep moving keep moving he gets around the disc corner and he
signals you guys to just lower yourself and just hide uh
oh but that would be like that fat dude like looking side to side like what can i get behind
Bob take care of your bird i'm not gonna fucking keep him always
the body just inside my spatula would take it away okay
there we go uh all right uh he goes well okay so we have to climb a bit and then there's this
window that i know has been open for a while no one closes it anyway so this place will be
heavily guarded okay so just try to stay as quiet as you possibly can and we can take down some
of the guards try to move in in software's office and maybe cadence is there it's the best hope i
have at this point all right just follow me he's gonna climb like by the side of this wall there's
gonna be what do you call it the fucking pipes going down like for water and everything he's gonna
climb up that uh can everyone make an acrobatics oh god
oh shit
it's gonna be 11 10 7 27 as he grabs one of the side pipes to get up he's feels it like it's
gonna maybe give up before it gets to like the big ones which is mouth is an aroma he goes okay
this might not be as full proof friend as i thought he looks an office and he goes look can you
fly me up there and the rest of us too uh i think i used maybe Bob i have no way of lifting him
uh if you get us up then we could just tie a rope around roman everyone will pull him up
just get it that sounds like great plan okay just don't make any noise okay no first find me up there
grabs you and he goes there's one guy to write around here
well but this you can actually still throw you you're 27
you can just walk up the fucking wall no it's not that he just calls off the pipe climbing
pen i plan it all together he's not just telling anyone yeah uh okay no
yeah maybe you could do that yeah you could just climb up anyway uh riff goes
all right now just stay low uh can you roll for stealth grace
all right let me move you inside i move you inside i move to go inside and i got
uh okay 15 20 10 24 okay uh who's gonna pull roman up
okay so if you're all pulling him up uh whoever failed the stealth please do not
uh and the rest uh i would say the rest would be able to pull him up except for if it's not
gonna pull him up uh can you do uh uh strength checks everyone i'm gonna take an average
it's a pool right we are pulling right yes powerful build
yeah but he's like one size larger than you oh yeah yeah okay okay it doesn't work okay
yeah right should there shrink save uh just check check no safe
to have it for me this guy seems to be messing around with the piano right in front of him
riff goes well all right just try to stay as quiet as you can uh melth as i start to walk
one of the layers of the floor creeks a bit but it's not enough to alert these people
um all right let me roll for t-core he doesn't have good strength so
okay yeah that should be enough
And this sorts an
use to
Cool
oh, I'm actually using myself, come on now, big roll, big roll. Oh, hell no. I'm actually
good enough. We're all my, oh my god. I don't know. As you step on one of the planks,
I just full on creeks. This guy turns around and this guy turns around and they're gonna
just walk up through here and these guys are gonna just walk up straight to you and they
just start to question riff. They're not like doing anything. Just pointing their guns
and moving towards riff as they go. All right, a member of House Sin. We're doing, you
don't have access to the backstage riff, looks at Baptiste, he looks at Malfa's and goes
now. So he's just gonna ask you to move and just fucking take him down. I hit him with
everything you have. Baptiste and Malfa's. No, he already said it. It's done. He hasn't
done anything. You know, as if anything happens. Okay, that's in that 20. Yeah. A roll for
damage and 13 will not hit. Okay, 36. Oh my god. Okay, Baptiste, what are you doing
with that? What are you doing, Baptiste? You know, it's just as soon as he said now,
he's just like instinct took over and I just won't knock his head. Knock him out or it does
blow his head open. And he just falls flat on the ground. Okay, the second one does hit Malfa's.
Do you want to do charger? It is charger, right? Yeah. I think 1d6 plus 5 1d80. It is charger.
I shouldn't have that. I used to charge that. Yeah, that's that's able to knock him out.
Okay, because he wasn't really ready. So he wouldn't even get a chance to alert anyone and
you can all just gang up on him and take him down. So I'm just gonna say you're rushing.
You just charge smack his head and both of these. This guy is unconscious. This guy is
just straight up dead. His head is like bleeding all over the floor. Oops. Yeah. God, what the
fuck? Just put them in a corner. Tie this one up. I'm an eagle. Okay, you put one of
them here and the other one just you just time over here. All right. Oh, uh, Baptiste,
this one is turning around. He did not really see you do anything, but you guys start to
hear this music coming from the center off like this grand orchestral opera type of music
coming from the center of this stage. This supposed this looks to be the stage. All right.
Sen goes this time just. Romakin, you just try to not walk as fast.
Bro, that was I was climbing through the window.
Just not or shake your head. Yes. Okay. Let's come up with y'all. Pop in the air. Okay. Okay.
Now I'm gonna just do this because it's gonna be easier so we know how much distance everyone's
moving. Okay. Okay. Are going this way. Yes. You're just falling sin, right? Yeah,
right. Okay. Roll for initiative. All right. So, I'm a Bob. I think you're right. Okay.
I'm beginning. Okay. Uh, Rift looks at you about these. He goes. Okay. Can you move and take that guy down?
I don't know if you shit, bro. Does movement matter in this sexy? Yes. Movement will matter.
So because he will also move and turn around. Right? Yeah. I can't reach it. Yeah. So just just walk.
Just. No, not even brother bro. Can you make a stealth check as you're dashing behind him?
Yeah. That should be good enough. Does that mean I get advantage? Yeah. That's it. It's mostly a
rogue thing, but sure why not? 14 will be able to hit him. Okay. Yeah. That should be able to knock him off.
What do you want to do? I'm knocking him out. I'm knocking him out. Where do you want to put him?
Right. Touch the neck. I'm going to turn back to Rift and like point towards one of these doors to see if it's safe to open one.
He nods his head. He goes. It might be locked. Just leave the body in the corner or somewhere. I can't. He points to this place. I get in there. You can. I'll go around. You essentially go back around him. Grab him by his neck. And just choke him.
And you just throw him to the side. And Bob. Malfus and everyone. I think at this point, I'll say for this turn, everyone. No, no, everyone for this turn is just going to make the movement to catch up to about these.
All right. There you go. All right. Rift goes to this corner. I don't know why you can't move. Okay. Rift goes to get this corner. He peeks around. He goes. There's two guards. Who was able to take him off one by one?
Who's going to try? Come on. Because decision fast. Malfus going. Malfus. Malfus. Go.
T-Gore just looks back at you. Bob and he goes rock paper scissors. No, let them take care of it. Okay. All right. Who's going? Who's going? Malfus. Both of you are going or who's going? Because two people need to go simultaneously and just take him out.
Yeah. You have full movement. Yeah. That's what I'm saying. It's going to be a bad release. I see. It's like 15 and then 15 this way. Yeah. You can you can move to the top two, I think. Yeah. Go ahead.
I think you're like using the scales and not like moving moving. You have to select the token.
Okay. Anyone move. Yeah. Oh, I think. Yeah. The people who are who's turn it is is the only one who can. Okay. It's fine. All right. Go ahead.
Will it be better if you both. I think playing on the second first one and I'm playing on the second one. Again, you she see this is like this one. I'm talking about you can better game. It's like you have to work with what you have.
If you're sorry, like, yeah, attack them at the same time, simultaneously. Because if you hit one, the other one will be able to alert everyone. Right. Yeah. That's what my logic is. One would have to attack one. One would have to attack the other. Yeah. I attacked. I don't know if you hit.
What was it 12. Yeah. 12 doesn't it. I bet I'm a mouth.
See, I had like the opera music and everything going. It's just fucking ruined. Everything's ruined because I fucking swish.
Stop. I'm like fucking. Yeah. That does not hit. Okay. Roll once again. 21 does hit.
Roll for damage, Baptiste.
14 does hit.
Well, for damage.
17 is going to knock him out. Okay.
So what are you guys doing? 13 is also going to knock him out. So what are you guys doing at the same time you both.
Baptiste in your case, you just jump and just dash your way in to this guy and Alpha. You dash your way into the other guy.
So we both miss our first points. And then land at the same time.
You both come up. They start pointing their guns at you. They shoot. You miss one of the punches and the other hook.
I guess you just both just knock him down both of them to this wall.
And this wall.
Other punches with that last we both miss and then we switch arms and then we both just land knock him out.
You both look like each other. Echo like, but only one has a way. All right. Good job.
Also, there's all of any. There's six of us on this team and only one person has doesn't have a huge.
He goes. Yeah, yeah, that's fine. That's fine. I'll I'll move you guys in. Let me do that. There we go.
That's a bit clunky. At some point, I'm like, what the fuck man?
I can't do that. Because there's there might be a sort of full on combat at some point.
It depends on how you people. Okay. Rift goes up to the door and he tries to open it.
Goes. Well, can someone open the door?
Roma. No, we can't make an sound at the top point. What are you saying, Roma for?
Is this good for doors? What do you mean it's good for doors? Can't break it down?
Yeah, I have a team's tools from I think the caller or something. Can I use that? Yeah, yeah.
I was just going to use it.
Wait a second. Can I give my teeth? Does anyone else have teeth to provisions so that I can give my teeth to them? Okay. I'll just try my with my teeth.
Roll through the use tools.
Okay. 21. Yeah. You should be able to get to the door. You see, like, you should be able to fit one of your fingers in and just she meet the door open.
You fit one of your fingers. It transformed into like this blade. Small blade. You tinker around in there and then the click happens and you should be able to open the door now.
Let me change the fuck man. Okay. Yeah. But at least you can open the door now.
Oh my swear to God. I swear to God. I'm going to kill myself. Okay. As soon as you open the door, you see a woman kind of like taking one of like a conductor's baton and just drilling the baton right into the forehead of this girl tied to one of the brass bars around this room.
You can pull the ball and grab the arm that she's using that baton. Okay. You grab her arm and you see this woman is really tall like seven feet and it's kind of intimidating as it turns around.
It goes fucking rat. There you touch me. You see, slaps your hand away and she just goes, where are my guards? Guards. And she calls for her guards.
And let's get into home. All right. Can you try to hit? I'm pleased.
Just to make sure I'm doing a regular attack with this. Okay. Okay. As you try to hit her. Let me see.
She does not have her shit. Sort of got the spell sheets are all fucked up. Okay. She's going to just do silvery barbs. You have to roll again.
What? How dare you copy my thing? You're okay. Okay. As you try to like slap her with one of your arms. She just points the baton at you and she just hits a high pitch note that just basically initially stuns you for a second and she gets back a bit and she goes, how dare you?
How dare you touch a lady? And yeah, that's going to start the combat. Okay. It's.
It's your turn, but he's go ahead. Let me see if she rolls better actually. No. Okay.
But she did call for her guards. Let me move them in just so I don't forget.
And you see out of the this door.
One of the guards comes in. She he surrounds lady. So frion. He goes. Truders. How did they get in? I don't know. You're supposed to know that.
Yeah. Is that happens? Another guard quickly follows. Inside. Yeah.
Yeah. They were right outside. This should be able to. I'd say as soon as I've seen so he just dashed in the did that and then all of this is happening.
Now you guys can continue. Okay. Baptiste. What are you doing? You see this girl right here who's tied to the breast. She also has this face mask.
And she just she at this point she's unconscious. Yeah, but she matches the picture that riff showed you.
Okay. I'm moving my arms. All right. These three. I do. Tax save. Normal.
One guy fails. Do the damage.
So for also fails. Okay. Let me add this to you. And then I would like to grapple the lady.
Okay. Do a strength.
The actual arms. I think. It's going to be 17. So you have to do a better one.
Yeah. I can use my with the modifier instead of drink for making shrink checks.
Just roll the wisdom.
As a bunch of your arms try to grab her with the actual arms. She again just opens her mouth and this high pitched noise comes out of it as all of these arms just stop midway before even touching her.
I'm going to try to do a little bit more. I'm going to try to do a little bit more.
Yeah. She's tied up with ropes. Yeah. So if I were to cut the ropes, grab her and run away.
Would I be able to do that? I mean, you can try.
Okay. So I probably don't have enough movement. So can I just can I just miss you step over here then cut the ropes and grab her and run away?
Okay. Go ahead. Would I have enough movement for that? Okay. Then I'll just.
Oh my god. Why did you call close the door? Are you closing the door?
Wait. Wait. Wait. Okay. Now you can move without closing the door.
There you go. Don't touch yourself. First of all. Okay.
And then I'm going to cut the ropes. Well, there's like steel lining is to the rope. You can try to cut it.
What is she attached to like a chair like a brass like pipes going through all of this room.
And you also can see like this window is completely made of glass. That's where the it's reflecting the sunlight is reflecting off on the ground.
Okay. So I drove to cut. Okay. Just normal.
I just go with luck on this one. No. I don't have anything with that. Okay. No. No. You don't have anything. What do you have that you can cut the rope with?
Just your hands. You can try to just pull them apart. And that's it. I mean, you can try try the dagger. What's the what's the modifier on the dagger?
Plus five. I think yeah, that should be enough to cut the rope actually. All right. So I'll just grab her and bolt away.
Okay. You can grab her, but you can't bolt away. That's not enough moment.
Let me let me. So show you this. So 25 is there. If you hover on your tokens, 25 is there on the gate.
So you can get her to the gate. No, not to the gate. Sorry, five feet. You can only get her five feet. That's it.
This is your moment. If you want to dash, you can dash. Yeah. This bonus action. Can you dash or the bonus action? No, I can't. I need my action.
Oh, you already missed this episode. No. Yeah. You can do anything. You free her. Do I have my action?
You don't have your action. Yeah. All right. Then I'll just burn them.
Okay. Go ahead.
Baptist. Can you move aside?
You can't next to me. Finger down.
You're playing for actually. Play for okay.
I love when people come right up next to you then ask you to move.
He saves. He also saves.
She also saves. I did the damage. It's 10 right. That's going to be.
Sorry. Why is it not automatically halved? I don't understand.
I'll have to leave after this fight because it's already a bit too late for me.
That's fine. That's fine. As you turn one of your hands into like this nozzle and the nozzle just shoots alcohol at first.
And then the small lighter pops up is one of your fingers and that catches on fire.
The clothes that this woman is wearing is like very shiny, glimmery glass and it just reflects off of it.
It does burn her a bit but not completely. And the other two just dodge it.
The flames. Alright. Memphis, you're turned.
You're doing that Bob. You also notice like there's a small window that opens up behind this girl as a hand pops out and grabs this girl from behind as the crowd.
That was applauding for a bit there. It disappears. The noise of the opera music that was going on and the crowd noises all disappear.
And you see like a hand just coming through and grab the girl out.
I don't see anything through the hole. You should be able to let me do the change in the hole. There we go.
Where's the hand? Oh, I'll never buy. Oh, what the hell is that?
She got a twin. No, it's just curtains.
Oh, you mean her. Yeah, you'll figure it out.
18 heads. So that's your charger, right?
Yeah. Yeah, as you just burst in, the shoulder this guy in just punches face. He's going to knock out.
Yep. I'm going to swap these guys because I accidentally killed this one.
Alright, the next guy. Alright, no, no, oh, you have one more.
Keep it going. Come on. Keep forgetting.
You know, it's been a mess all day. All day, it's been a mess.
We haven't fought in a while. So, yeah, it's been too special.
It wasn't supposed to be this messy, but you know, whatever.
Alright, yeah, the as soon as you get rid of this guy, you just throw him aside and just hit the other guy with another punch.
The lady at this point looks back. Who the hell are these fucking people?
Keep getting in my way. Roma, sir, turn.
I'm going to move there.
You can move inside. Yeah, there you go.
That's not safe. Can I not? Alright, so I see this girl.
I got how far was that 30 feet? I still got five feet of movement.
Fuck it. Bad Jesus right there. Who's that? Fuck it. I'm going to go there.
You're doing cold?
What? I thought you were doing the cold one that blinds everyone, but okay, it's okay.
No, I don't even have that anymore, bro.
What are you doing?
Transform?
Yeah, but I was trying to see if I got hybrid or full beat.
Hybrid hybrid. You can only do hybrid.
Just click, let me click on Transform.
There we go.
Why does it go 44? I don't get it.
I think my aunt Matt says wrong.
Alright, go ahead.
What I have in this form. You have everything I think that you have.
There we go. It's going to be all right.
You have natural weapons.
You remove natural weapons from that. Okay, that's fine.
Now I still have natural weapons.
It doesn't really do much.
Fuck it.
So I transform. That's my action bonus bonus.
No, that's bonus. Yeah.
Okay, that's the bonus. Well, fuck it. We swinging then.
Right or attack recklessly or no?
Yep.
Okay, apply recklessly. There you go.
Go ahead.
I get a swing with the advantage.
I'm hitting the, yeah, you're the woman.
Okay, yeah, that will hit.
11.
As one of your, you're doing with the skillet, right?
Okay, as one of your hits, lands right on her, like glass dress.
It gives a shockwave and that will hit her for five.
Oh my god, she was quite, I am going to.
Isn't your skillet 1D 12?
No, I think it's different.
Space damage is 1D8 plus 3.
And then to hit, I get a plus 5.
Are you ready?
No, no, no.
Yeah, I don't know.
What the, why is it targeting you?
I don't get it.
Why does it always target you?
Okay.
That's 11 actually.
I don't know why I said.
Okay, it's going to hit her.
Does she not get damaged by anything?
No, it got damaged by a bob.
Okay.
All right, that hits her and she is going to use her legendary action for the high note.
So can everyone make a?
Let me explain chat.
Oh god.
Is there no description as well?
Oh my god.
I don't know if I can have the look through when I was first.
I can give you one minute.
Make her performance great.
No, no, no.
You can get out of the finger.
Okay, anything that has glass or anything on you will shatter.
So the wild that you have, malphous, will shatter for the.
Yeah, which doesn't exist.
And the dust will essentially just break.
Oh, what is it just you saying like I don't want to make them anymore?
No, no, no, no, it's just like for flavor, I guess.
And she keeps going and she keeps going.
The next thing is you have to make a wisdom save.
You said everything glass shatters, correct?
Yes.
I didn't mean to roll that.
Not her dress.
If you're saying that.
No, her dress is made of different things.
It's not just glass.
Maybe it cracks.
Yeah, it cracks, but that's it.
Now, I'm going to just fall off.
That is keep it in your pants.
You said it.
Oh my god.
Wisdom save, wisdom save, wisdom save.
Baptism save.
Question.
If mouth has had the powder like in his pocket, wouldn't it just be in his pocket just
not in a while?
Why is Roma at the end?
Why did I skip everyone else?
What is happening with this fucking thing?
I was right behind fucking mouth.
Okay.
What?
And then I got moved.
19 damn holy shit none of you fail okay she's gonna keep going. I have no idea. No it's not -1 +1 what do you mean?
Yeah, -1 is from your -1 in wisdom yeah my god
right she's gonna keep going and this time a massive shockwave repels from her
body and everyone in the area will take damage even the guys here
and that's gonna be
making our work easier
well thank you we're help
that's 15 damage to everyone what kind?
Thunder
No, this is without any saves it was just supposed to happen
the whole time she's hitting this note I couldn't have just like smacked her face with my
hand or hit her throat like no she's just hitting the note you're just this this oriented all this time
uh all right uh these two guys are dead
yeah
and
and the girl is now you can see her getting away someone's dragging her away
get her off uh it's Tegor's turn he still has no idea what is happening so he's just gonna run in
go for the girl he doesn't know no point
no I'm saying that as he runs in
where's the girl
I'll just point in the girl direction like the
well okay well okay he's gonna dash uh and that's gonna be another 30 feet that's it he's
around here you see he's the girl uh all right it's her turn
and she goes useless people now what should be so kind to help me
kind sir he looks at uh Roma Roma make uh oh no oh no I'm gonna make uh
wisdom safe no you're gonna kill her bro she's gonna make you kill her
oh she said wisdom oh you fuck your fuck no all right your charm drama unless she or her allies
hit you you will not come out of the charm or I think you can make
saving throws every turn right charm ends regardless of the friendly acquaintance
if the charm ends uh the charm creature regards you as a friendly acquaintance when the spell ends
the creature knows uh knows it was charm right you okay uh does it so with advantage you so with
advantage you attempted to charm a human eye you can see within range it makes a wisdom saving
throw and does so with advantage if you are your oh do it with the vanish do another one
and your companions are fighting if you and your companions are oh yeah she did hit you so yeah
do it again uh oh okay if it fails to saving throw uh all right what do you say to her
okay she's just gonna do this uh all quite hard that's gonna be her turn uh it's gonna be
riff he steps in goes where's cadence I'll point the same way I pointed to tick off okay he's gonna run
there he's gonna dash and he goes there's two of you what the fuck is happening and he's going to
first of all oh let me see he did dash right okay yeah that says that's his turn uh all right
Roma is already yeah left his your turn
maneuver all right swing
uh Bob let me know if you have to go we can pause it anytime okay just don't stick around if you
have to go I mean I mean Baptist can finish the fight now that's not gonna go much longer
does that mean he seems to get ahead on the same thing okay sure I had 18 will head
another one
oh that was so close to a crit 14 will hit
yeah she's she's not wearing anything and then the fucking dress bro what do you think uh 17
and what was the other one 18 under the glasses uh it's more than 30 right yeah
what do you want to do doesn't allow me to take whether it's the astral arms or not but those were
both using the action so that's fine she's gonna take this red dot logo blow out her fucking throw
so she can't head another high enough
what do you want to do oh that took her down yeah oh you want to kill her you want to save her
or knock her out what do you want to well see I saw another version of her in the other room so
I'm confused what's going on so yeah first it's a jab to the throat to make sure she can't
think okay then it is just a punch to the gut to knock her out and it just so happened to be where
the dress was cracked okay yeah she's knocked out at this point
and then I'm moving I keep touching this door then I'm moving over oh my god this door is pissing me
all yeah you can always use the arrow keys by the way right you're not used to it but it doesn't
let you move if there's something in front of you oh yeah okay all right Bob's return
run over here oh wait too far sorry what don't be confused their twins just fucking fight
it's she is she's still unconscious yeah yeah she's just getting dragged
okay girl that girl is huge
like seven feet tug of war you're not yeah let's do tug of war you see more people are coming around
oh god
nope I have nothing I don't have enough stuff
tug of war it has been what tug of war okay yes okay you're gonna do a strength
oh is it okay okay we have full
unless you pull the zero Bob Bob listen what the fuck that's the funny shit I've seen all
this why why would he have advantage because he's no five-word thingy no I don't think so that
doesn't matter so not in tug of war okay look look look red is also pulling with me right
breath is not doing it oh he's not he's not fucking pulling each oh wait
it's a tie
mm-hmm it just stops because he had a higher hole
no no that's not how it works that's not how it works just because he has a natural higher
roll doesn't mean he's not weak as shit okay
no no no let's let's move on you just fucking pulling apart all right mouth as you're turned
mm yeah she right after Bob's turn by the way she's gonna do it again the high note so first
make a wisdom save all the glass again shatters no no it's an a o it's sound based so it's not
gonna be like anything you will get hit by the yeah I know yeah I'm pretty sure I'm down I don't
even have to check let me roll 46 wait this is the one that does damage no it's always the one that
does damage it it happens in three stages that's it oh I'm a duo I'm down but do make a wisdom save
everyone yeah if it's everyone that anyone can who can hear it has to make one can I use my bell
you what dial bell bell you can make up yeah you can't re-roll
uh Roma you save mouth as you don't save bob you don't save
Malfa's from now on every attack would be done with the disadvantage because you have a tear in
your ear bob you don't you save map tees you save yeah Malfa's you have permanent disadvantage for now
well 11 would knock you down
yeah I have so many speed oh god it will also knock me down yeah it will knock you down
uh DMI have a question yes the skewer wounds that are mulling cast that is not uh that mulling does
that not me right no no I'm not gonna let you do that first of all no
uh no yeah fair that's fair
season for gag uh it's gonna be 11 for you too so that's gonna be 9
uh for Roma as well it's gonna be 11 so you're at 11 actually 12 and then zero temp
right uh T-Gorus also going to take damage
to do wisdom save as well just so you know T-Gor does not have a lot of HP
I'm letting you know this if in case he goes dice and he then blame me
oh god he saves the wisdom he fails to do the system as well um he goes that if T-Gorus goes down
does he die automatically he will no no he will have that saving him he's an importantness in PC so
I'm not gonna just straight up kill him uh all right everyone is taking damage and even her
but just for the sake of it I'm not gonna say she dies I'll say some things died around her
year so she can't die from the thing uh but she's still unconscious uh Malfa's is down
uh Bob is down T-Gor yeah yeah go ahead Roma
well I don't think it's gonna let me just it's not somehow to let me move you here
oh you know she hit me without shit come on now
right rage
it's exactly thirty feet that's crazy
uh reckless there we go
and everything is not working
oh my god you're still kind of like imbalanced from the screen that she did earlier so you just
miss uh your skillet head as she turns around she goes all of you are fucking useless
soldiers come on shoot them down uh three of the soldiers uh turn around get around the corners
and they will just start shooting you in cover uh
go rubber pistol check normal
i don't think i'm making it rubber pistol check
rubber pistol
neck
thirteen sixteen and ten sixteen
does it hit you Roma where are they shooting you you you well hit you're the closest one to her
so you're just gonna target you okay it does hit i think others don't hit
uh that's eight
oh what that's four nice because it's bludgeoning all right uh ask one bullet fires off the couple
of others don't really do much but the one just hits you in the sternum as you take a uh
step back and uh it's gonna be
Hugh Tigor is gonna grab bob as he sees bob falling down and he's going to take you back here
with malphous uh so he can protect you i guess uh
that's gonna be Tigor's turn my hero it's so first turn and she is going to look at
Baptiste and she goes on chew a charming one now
you help me uh make a wisdom save she has not hit and hit hit you i mean yeah she did hit you
okay make a difference in manage make it revenge
i don't think it should count because it's like an e o e but sure
i know where the damage is coming from oh my god
Baptiste you are under the charm you cannot uh hit her or you will have to follow her commands for
them now unless one of them shoots you uh her singing voice essentially like brings back
these memories of uh the mermaid and you just see uh her just capturing you and she goes
now put your beard here and take care of this ruffian right here if you point at uh riff
it's riff's turn and he goes god damn it okay uh he will
um it's a short rest thing does not have any healing stuff
well i guess there's only one way he can do it
he can't give Baptiste body inspiration did you want him to kill him
uh he will ask aroma something
okay rumm can you tell me something that might snap Baptiste out of the
fucking uh hypnotism that she put him under
rummah is a mercenate way
mean i tell you just fuck the bitch up and he'll be okay come on hit the bitch
okay i trust you i'm gonna give you something to go off off and he starts to riff uh his guitar
and that's gonna be part of conspiracy for you uh okay a d6 whenever you want to use
that it's a bonus action and then he's gonna take his rubber shotgun and just shoot her
don't know
okay he misses uh as one of the the rubber shotgun goes like right through her neck she goes
now that's not very nice is it uh and see your turn rummah no that's not your turn sorry uh Baptiste
okay am i just charmed or was i commanded you are charmed
so that just means i can't attack her can't attack her but she will ask you to do something for her
doesn't mean i have to fuck a lot no no that's not that's not how it's not how charm works does it
charm just means you can't attack her yeah but then she she's going to
she's going to ask you to kill him man it's up to you it's up to you honestly
she has she literally has
okay okay come on we're gonna do that we're gonna do that
come on rummah it's not you it's Baptiste he's gonna know what she what she means the Baptiste
no Baptiste is gonna be like i need you to be descriptive come on now with that
he's gonna be like take care of you need to knock him out no no no okay okay how about this you make
another wisdom save if you succeed i'll say you will not move that's it i'm not letting you
attack anyone else but though it's it's it's Baptiste character he's going what specific orders like
kill or incapacitate or maybe bring him a couple of tea yeah it's enough you start to walk to
word riff and just stop yourself for a second you cannot move there's a lot of things going on in
your head she was dead why she here why can't i hear her and stuff like that that's just the
stuff going through your head at this point Bob can you make it that safe yeah okay
mouth is make a dead save it's your turn rummah question would what Tigger have been like
okay you know i'm gonna have to do this real quick what what do you try and fast
armor of armor of agathus let me you're in the water see no in he gets like spells from his
double fruits ring armor of agathus let me do that cast spell consume just click off consume spell
slots when the fuck do you see that and you click on armor like agathus you could do class spells
and then that it says they could checkbox consume spell slots just don't do that yeah
okay there you go i applied it on you and did you give me the health too plus five
and does it not give you it remind me apply effects there you go apply active effects
what it doesn't go to the temp or which
oh sorry sorry okay but anyway so then
that should be my does that my boat that's the bonus right yeah that's your bonus what do you
want to do next it this white mist of like snow just covers you for a second as you feel yourself
getting degraded uh yeah what do you want to do with the poetic expression like a recklessly do
it with advantage eight nineteen nineteen does it just say no she has not taken a single hit so far
all right uh uh what the fuck when uh no no no more i think it's just normal
slashing what why would the skillet do
i thought because i have the armor plus five the cold damage
wait plus five to cold damage what where does it say that that's what it says right here when
i'm hovering over it says any creatures if a creature hits you devils a four five cold damage
yeah yeah okay perfect no mind uh wait do you get five separate parts yeah okay uh so basically
this like layer of cold snow is around you and they will latch on to anyone hitting you uh
yeah uh okay to the throat uh and it's gonna be tiger tiger is going to maybe grab something
from your bag maybe look around you do have a small med kit and he's gonna just do that
okay that's cool no malphous he's bringing malphous up wait what i can heal i can literally heal people
the fuck he doesn't know that oh yeah yeah he brings malphous up and that's his bonus right
i'm gonna use his action as well to bring you up
he's gonna use malphous's kit again roll
and you can figure that out later on yourself okay i don't care
all right so you guys are both up at this point Tiko looks at you guys okay i just found
whatever i could and try to get you up as soon as the back he says gone mad he's trying to kill
riff dude great job okay just get still away you did a great job but it's her turn and she is going to
use shatter oh they got to the radius and she's gonna hit another high-pitch note and
she's gonna target you Roma and her riff let me do that oh i'm dead cast what Roma
concept yeah i'm gonna i'm gonna drop out of the hybrid form okay you're not gonna die
you're just gonna revert back to whatever full hpu had in base form
hybrid but no matter what like whatever they hit i'm gonna go out of hybrid
well it's fine yeah yeah can't save can't save
riff is going to succeed but he still takes 11 damage
and Roma you succeed you also take 11 damage so that's 0 and then 132 you're at 2hp
all right as her like loud note just hits you right in your ears and you start to bleed
refusely but you're still on down you're still conscious it's gonna be riffs turn he goes
i've had enough the shit and he's going to start riffing on his guitar and then
sparks are going to fly off and he's gonna hit her back with the shatter
oh yeah this this is what we have been waiting for is her charm not concentration
it is it is so once she loses that it's gonna drop nice she fails
i don't think he did after let me let me make on save i don't think because it pops up if it is
let me check actually charm person no no it's not that okay uh it's gonna hit her for 13
right uh it's gonna be his turn it's your turn about he's you're still make wisdom
which uh she doesn't her concentration is still intact yes she doesn't need to concentrate
oh yeah charm is in concentration yeah yeah yeah yeah
wisdom save baptize otherwise you go kill riff oh all right time to kill him everything you have
and i mean everything you have if you're gonna pull any bolt it i'm gonna pull some bolt it too
yeah that doesn't hit would she use shatter would he have been hit by that
no no he was out of range okay i just want to make sure yeah
yeah that says it's him
well if it's a nice knowing your buddy uh
or like to get his heartic inspiration since i haven't used it
uh okay 23 let me see it's not gonna be more than his total HP so he's just gonna
go unconscious he does not really even notice you coming behind him you show up behind him
i just boom straight in his head uh he's gonna fall unconscious
and after this he's gonna go well if it is in my hero now could you play at least take care of
this beast right here uh yeah yeah yeah think he's trying to say that in like a very
graspy voice about that all right Bob sir turn sir turn
everything is so the other guy's by the way these guys are down because of the
i know cool cool how how bad does Roma look like he still has his pho hb
no no he looks very torn right now okay damn it yeah uh q1's and Roma true ones are Roma okay
you know what no Roma can take it
i mean it's Roma right
good i'm sitting on two hp for now you have to remember Bob let me say on one hp for a whole fight
he's back there yeah oh i worry right hope what are you doing
here uh tuned who uh Roma okay
all right i mean i asked who do Roma these little critters
climb all over you your fur and they keep going inside as they start biting you
and you feel uncomfortable at first and then you're like oh i feel better my wounds are
closing up what the hell and then how much movement do i have uh you have 20 feet
you know what no i don't have enough help to risk that i end up turn okay all right valve is your turn
you just woke up you can hear a bunch of noises from here and you can see that this this
tin wall you can easily break through it you can just go through you can go through if you want to
just just fucking straight just crash okay what are you doing you're knocking out Baptiste what are you
you see Baptiste standing over uh riff and his foot is on his head
oh i'm gonna try to talk about this out of it
all right Baptiste do you make another wisdom save and what do you say about
the mouth is
you
all right roll uh roll charisma and Baptiste's role wisdom
i feel like okay her last order was the target Roma yeah
why would just brought up the wings again with you now
we're not gonna say that was in character yeah please uh okay that's 20 okay that's nice
Baptiste you snap out of it and you just feel this infernal
raging within you for one second you for one second you thought you had her back
all right now my mouth is your turn what
like get a free legendary action no no
just wait your turn wait your turn my mouth is what you're doing
just moving here
there we go i'm still keeping my foot on
rift said yeah you just realized that your foot is on rift said what what have you
want to do you can take it off or whatever no i'm adding like i'm still under for control
okay
okay attack off just put me back put me back at the door
this i can only move
it's it's fine what what are we doing just tell me what you want to do all right all right
Roma it's your turn all right well
you still think Baptiste is coming to you by the way i don't give a fit in my eyes to get
that he's out of that thing i got a fuck her up so yeah go ahead
like recklessly do with advantage
and i will hit
and other ten and this point you just see she's starting to bleed
with your pants right at her face
oh my savior would you save me from this beast
it's tigor's turn tigor is just back here he looks at you bob
should we should we go help them but Baptiste is fucking people up okay okay
it's her turn and she is going to
to
let me make another dexay first and then we'll see if she can hit thine up
please don't yeah yeah she feels she tries to sing but her walkroom cards just not
they can't do anything she looks at you with this puppy eyes Roma and she will ask you to help her
again oh that piece of shit oh shit oh what do i gotta do to not hurt me anymore
uh is always himself advantage advantage
oh you fucked oh i wrote the net 20 yeah you're just at this point when she looks back at you
and you just see all of your friends lying down hurt it's just again you just feel this rage inside
of you i'm gonna make a death save that saves i'm gonna roll the dead save
oh sorry then i roll that save
he fails uh yeah Baptiste you're turned save me save me
that's what she's saying what a few kill them yeah miss we have to get out of here
okay i can't freaking move there you go
i want to be right here right right right behind and then i'll
i'm telling her we need to leave and then i'll reach out
mm-hmm like the grapple to go mm-hmm
try again as you grab her she kind of she kind of slips as
right over here as she slips down what key key key okay finally one more
yeah that was it that was it thank god you you're still my kill oh you some
21 okay let me see yeah that will that will be able to end her what do you do i'm really just
pim-slapping her as i'm gonna say you don't miss any of that it's just like uh series of just you
know when Goku just slapped the shit out of freezer that scene essentially
is just blood pouring out what i said the first two weren't meant to do damage he was this
yeah it was just you bitch you bitch and the last one just fucking slam her right into the ground
and yeah she's just gonna fucking spoiler some blood out and that's it and as soon as that happens
the alarm starts ringing and you hear a big explosion go off near like this area
where the guards were stationed at i will try to stabilize risks okay you can not do that
because you don't have a med kid i do have a med kid you do when oh you have oh you have a med
kid med i thought dnd med kit sorry uh yeah we can roll the med kit healing potion you mean
it says my target is blocked by a wall so it's not letting uh there you go
what do you mean you try to just roll the med kit it doesn't matter i'm gonna leave
pressure you use med kit it is okay let me let me let me roll it for you
what are you targeting it all okay roll roll the healing
my permission is blocked now oh my god swear to god i'm gonna kill myself
one day one of these days i'll figure out fine rear okay uh
riff riff comes back like conscious he goes what the hell was that what you
oh it's fine i know i know it can be those two can be fucking tough dude we gotta run
what what happened there's a blast over there and
alarms are ringing everywhere we're gonna run now you got a wave oh god oh no this is the worst
possible thing that could have happened uh after the blast rift starts to move away and she goes
can you grab cadence please just grab her and bring her here i'm too tired to do anything at this
point uh who's subscribing cadence what we killed that bitch i didn't mean to do that god damn it
all right there you go i grabbed her can't grab her shit i'm off the cool
uh we we're still in combat i think no no no you guys are out on bad
what i said i wanted to take twins hostage and rumours that we killed one
we killed them both no no i'm not i'm not the both of both of them were unconscious yeah
uh as you guys move through you see this whole wall is collapsed at this point as you walk out
you see on on the tower that the upper house was opposite to the white lights at this point have
all turned red and the sirens are going off all the nobles that were walking the streets have
now cleared the area and you see five figures standing on top of the towers like small balcony
as they stand up uh here voice go my check one two do we have any kind of cotton with us
seem like anything no are you sure Roma doesn't have candies no no no no no um and the red legs above
starts to like tick tick tick tick tick keep keep going up as the white white fades the red lights
keeps going up and uh riff at this point the riff has just turned pale he uh like he said like
it's like the worst possible uh scenario for him he goes oh no not them those are the soundless
the imperceptional guard if they are out then the control room is completely locked down we can't
hack it we need physical keys there's no way to get through uh and the figure keeps continuing um as
you guys are talking with each other trying to figure out what's happening dude we need to hide
I hate waking up with this ruckus the emperor has given you weaklings too much freedom to roam around
on the less outsiders that's in closely this is your final and last warning leave for your voices
will be forever silenced uh okay you're talking to each other at this point because he's not
gonna stop he can't listen to you he's just he's just talking through a microphone no no no no no no no no okay I'm
going to try to stop okay riff let's leave there's no point we're going to die if you want to leave
you leave I'm not an outsider I'm gonna stay here he told us to leave then leave you're the outsider's
not me he's not talking to me I'm sentenced to death do you understand you do not know of any
hiding spots any other tunnels there's no point hiding they're asking you to leave not me you
would do you not understand they will start attacking soon as a step as I step another foot out do
understand just leave do we get out about that who are you talking to
why was I on the speaker you're not on the speaker who said you're on the speaker
he said who ever it means okay I don't think he you need a speaker Roma but he can't listen to you
ghost what the hell is that thing you're talking about if we leave do we get our boat back
what is this boat business he's speaking over the microphone and bro just listen Jesus
cries the no one fucking listens everyone's talking yeah can you listen for one second no I'm talking to
Roma can you like either don't talk if you're not going to listen or just move on it's not going to
be like oh you talk I can't even say one thing before you start talking again okay okay we're all
muted just just just making making sure because if you're asking him then he needs to reply right
who you asking first of all let me let me clear this so I don't fucking lose my mind
okay so can I can I can I say something or before you start saying okay cool this is just making
sure okay he goes to he asks the people around him that what the speaker business is he goes
oh well get these strangers their fucking shipment let them leave
now send better surrender yourself you don't want to kill and for the commoners we'll find
each and every one that we're supporting you and we'll put them to that as usual he turns off
the mic and he starts to walk away so you guys are leaving then Bob is going to look at uh ref and
whisper to him so when do you think the um dead sentence would be like once the nearest time
it's now Bob what do you mean nearest time they're sending their army right down
right now they're coming down to kill me right now like not even a procedure
you're thinking they're there's this is lawful you think those people down there shackled by their
mouths that's lawful see that bell he points to a bell on top of the broadcast hour there's the
old liberty bell that thing has been there for about 500 years and none of us not a single rebellion
can get get on to there and bring these people down he keeps it there as a symbol that we can't
harm him we can't do anything other than cover behind these walls and that's it if you want to run
away that's fine with me from staying even if it that means death uh Bob uh you can zoom in with your
lenses and you can see that your shot right at this moment can take down that bell and with that that
bell might crush the five people standing on top what are you doing yeah it will come down to a role
right yeah it will come down to a role there on the balcony hey uh riff you know maybe
is then so could you sing for us one last time he's telling this to you by the everyone can hear him
right it's not like he's just talking to Bob
if I had my wings I'd fly up there but I don't
somebody I have seven days fee everyone besides me who has the inspiration
uh wait wait wait uh hey the him yeah was the thing about inspiration again
it's not the normal the in the role again right what what is it uh it's it's like
some form of hockey it depends on what you're trying to do and for an attack roll it would be like
if you hit it it's always it's all it's gonna depend on the hit but it's mostly for
cinematics nothing else I'll add like plus three for observation plus three for armament but that's
about it it's not gonna add like plus three to attack or something it will it will
so everyone except for Baptiste has inspiration right now yes this is an inspiration farming moment
what are you doing you're you're losing this it is indeed it is indeed one but
alright Baptiste what are you doing I'm asking one by one what is everyone doing Roma what are you doing
how far is that Liberty Bell it's pretty far up I mean you can try but it's gonna be
diva disadvantage it's pretty far away the only thing that can get to it is probably the
told the dead because it doesn't need like a attack role okay yeah I failed my wisdom
living through so I'm going for it okay not not on anyone's command you're just going for it I
failed my wisdom saving through I don't know I I thought if I pass it then I'll be his normal
self yourself but I I don't know that I failed it okay mouth as you're not doing anything
can you come on well I'm seeing if he's gonna shoot because the feet of the shoes that I'm
for it I don't know he shouldn't so told the dead roll it roll it's not in a check roll
so what do you do explain to me what do you do do you want to use the inspiration or no
yes I am I'm going to use everything everything that you gave me I'm going to use it right now
because this might be the last session if we know Bob you start to walk in front Baptiste you notice him
Bob you look at Baptiste Baptiste you look at Bob you see Baptiste no Baptiste sorry what what
fucking you see Bob's arm just slit open and Baptiste you know what he's about to do he's
basically looking at you to ask for approval I'm going to turn to riff mm-hmm I'll do before we came
to help and that's what we're going to do no more cowardry Bob do it and he shoots okay Bobby
pull your hand up and for one second your eyes just lock onto that bell and you shoot as your
bullet hits the bell very lightly it for the first time in 500 years just dings like this
loud bell noise goes through and those five figures stop and turn around as the bell starts to
crack and the holdings start to give up as the bell starts to drop gravity takes hold the bells
falls like a meteor crashing into the shadows of the five figures riff kind of looking up toward
that bell stands up and for the first time he has hope and the bell starts tumbling down still
tumbling over the broadcast hour but none of them move the five figures just stay still he
doesn't even look up the two figures right around him one of them a big massive man and a woman
with like a blade long blade around her back both of them just jump up and splash the bells into
like three pieces and those three pieces just go tumbling down and they fall right in front here
no explosion no crash the massive bells just spills in like four quarters the pieces
sidelessly like slight harmlessly pass the balcony crashing into the streets below as the ground shakes
the five figures essentially remain untouched the main guy that had the speakers just does his
shoulder he steps up into the light you can see him now he's wearing this white coat and he has like
tie a wrap around his neck kind of like the Marines that tie around their neck like
the blue collar ties whatever and he steps up he goes
where are you well then it don't seem to be the same breed of coward like these commoners
you have spirit i'll give you one chance let's play a game shall we
he takes something out of his pocket as he dangles the chain and in the sunlight
light flickers off of the thing and you can tell
what the fuck is happening what's being in the background yeah i don't know what's happening this
session is cursed that's all i'm gonna say as the uh glimmer off of the key hits you he says
we will wait for you inside the tower level one two three all the way up
and the all of the rest of the people starts to come into the light one like a big hulky dude
still are kind of like the same armor that the previous guy was wearing but this one is like even
bigger probably even bigger than you mouth is um and uh another guy with like a bunch of like
rope tying around him like a bunch of equipment uh and he steps out uh the the girl that was right
aside on the left side of him steps out with the sniper around her back and a big ballad attached
to that sniper another guy steps out he has the these two like small um like sickle blades
around his arms as he jumps up onto the balcony's wall as he crouches down with his hair flowing
green um and they all essentially show you this key and he goes if you get all the five keys
you can knock the control room as opposed that is what you're after aren't you
and when you lock the control room you win
it smiles vanishes for a second the air kind of gets cold everything slows down
but we warn you are raising the clock the emperors stirring if you wake up fully before you
reach the top you won't fight him you will just bow much like the rest of us
the five figures at this point just turn around and start walking back into the tower the heavy
blast doors that opened up on the balcony just shut down and that's gonna be the end of the session
holy fuck
yeeees
so long rest?
long rest yes
i mean they essentially invited you in so no one's gonna come after you i'm sorry room
i got like fucking kind of pissed with the with the whole thing of the whole session i got
i got a little stressed i don't worry uh okay uh i didn't i didn't i didn't mean to be mean when
you're playing a character and everything but it's like yeah i got it too frustrated yeah okay
uh i don't know but i kakashi going to a rage i did when i did
bro i swear to god i i hate it i hate it so much i prepped so much for this whole thing
and everything kept falling apart right from the get go like why where did all my tokens go what the
fuck is happening uh it was great though hopefully it was great nothing too great all right i'm gonna
let you know what i'm trying to do next session it is going to be one of those classic one we won
on one piece fights so you gotta you gotta be ready you gotta be on your like dnd uh you know
top four what do we pick one already i mean it's you have your rankings what do you mean you don't
need to pick one it will happen naturally yeah well bobo there's five there's five
riff riff and t-gore will fight one guy and then you guys can go off one on one
does the girl wake up in this time uh not not now let's start at next session i think bob has to go
anywhere by the way how long is next session next session is not going to be next week because i
think Roma is busy right so uh if you guys want to do a side story or backstory for your characters
or anything let me know i think bob you have nothing for your back stories i might prep something for
your back story we can do that or we can just do a side quest yeah that's fine then i
okay so you can't be next week right you can show up next week yeah yeah that's fine
that's good that's fine uh baptize in mouth you guys can decide if you want to do a side quest
thing or not now teased next week all right uh anything anything other than the shitty
fucking session the foundry bullshit okay that's not that shouldn't be the fun part i was horrified
after like two seconds later why bro that's why and also i somehow managed to get a zero
yeah that's crazy anyway good night people i gotta go home yeah good night good night
we i appreciate you letting us fuck people up yeah i was an holding back and i told you guys
that it's it's going to be an easy walk because they're like none of the like guards and stuff
well the guards and stuff were easy right they were they were also they were all going down in like
one-hits at most uh well yeah the encounter was a bit tough yeah i think malphys would not have
gone down unless like uh whatever happened last right? You were I think Malfa's you were
expecting this that fucking tank guy to be tough, but he really wasn't. Yeah yeah yeah, yeah.
So will cadence not wake up before we go into the tower? No no, she will wake up by the next session
so at the start of the story. So again you have like eight hours right they're not gonna send
anyone they're gonna do anything they're just saying come in. You said one day one each. Yes.
So which one have I fight a? Uh the the uh yeah I guess you will see yeah. Oh
I wanna know. Just be on your A game it's not gonna be bad if anything goes wrong I have a backup
and it's gonna be very cool the backup thing that I've planned so uh I'm gonna drop. He's a
level four uh yeah also remember what I said about leveling up last time?
No. Okay so I said it will happen in the middle of a fight right?
So right now. No so no no no no no no no first first of all pick what you want first of all
so it doesn't need to be like all picked up right at this moment whatever you want to trigger your
level up that is basically the triggering move let's say you get a new feet or something so you use
it yeah so you use it and then that will level you up but again no health resets.
It will just get you the help that you get from that level but that's about it.
Okay. You will not heal completely. If anyone loses in your fight it's most gonna be me.
What? I keep thinking. Yeah if you keep me well that's that's the thing right you can do your
unarmed straights. You you will have all your abilities it's up to you what you want to do.
Also there's it's gonna die of no more if there's the first one it's probably gonna be.
I feel like the problem right now what is happening is you guys are in combat a lot with the
groups of people but then we like don't talk within the combat and that's that's a problem that's
we've been having for a while so none of the characters are being developed in any like meaningful
way that's why I want to have like one V1 so each character has to get to interact with the other
whatever they're fighting right whoever they're fighting. Just gonna be one round of two people
fighting talking then we switch to other person they're fighting talking they're fighting talking
but I don't think one round would be enough so I'll say maybe like two or three rounds we'll go
for two people and then we'll switch because that will feel more you know better because instead of
like fucking doing one attack and then switching then switching then switching then that's
takes a while. We also get stunning strike. Yeah exactly. I'm also looking at so whatever look at your
level what do you get on the next level and just let me know what you're triggering is it can be
an emotional moment it can be just a cinematic thing if you hit a nat 20 feel free dude fucking just
go in whatever and I have a little surprise at the end of it so it's gonna be fun. No no no
that's not going double level though I don't know why you're thinking with this level of bullshit.
I'm also gonna send what happened to the other crew by next week so you get just be sure to read
that as well because that will kind of help you make decisions from now on right where you want to
go and stuff like that. Yeah yeah yeah side mission is a separate thing. Yeah but next week
yeah next week next week. No you're going ahead. Okay so you're saying you want to do the what
happened to the other crew next week. You say that? Malfus? No I'm just asking if we're doing that
or not doing something or not next week. Yeah yeah we're doing you and that is right.
Yeah. Okay yeah yeah I'm good with that I have no problem
as long as you guys can shop. I'm good to do another session.
Do you want to do it an extra attack or something?
Well no it's the one. Yeah one. Yeah I'm three and one.
Oh three and one. Yeah you can get one feet for three to four you get one
feet one extra feet. Or you get the action search or I think the second one. Wait fighter level
two does get something what do you mean? Yeah do you want a level fighter or do you want to get
barbarian? Because barbarian will also at level four will get either ability score improvements
or one feet. Yeah. Or I can get two attacks with fighter. Yeah action search right?
Yeah yeah you can do that. Yeah I'm doing fighter.
I can swing my pain twice and then frenzy would frenzy be a third attack then?
frenzy is third attack but then you get an exhaustion. Yeah you can change it I think I'm pretty sure.
frenzy is a bonus right? And action search is also a bonus you can't do both of them in one.
Action search gives you yeah action search is a free action that gives you action bonus action
and movement right? Or does it not give it a direction? I'd get two attacks like two.
Okay it does give you action. I'd pop frenzy would be a third attack. Yeah yeah yeah checks out checks out.
That's fucking nasty. Hell yeah. Yeah so maybe save that for the finishing move or something.
But no you get exhausted after the fight has ended yeah. Yeah if I level up mid fight
it'll be actually be much easier for me to solo. I have a stride in my mind now using my level up.
Again level up is not going to reset your health just making sure you know that.
I'm not worried about the health part. I'm worried about me doing damage.
Oh I see. I see.